[Musik]
zdf heute live ganz herzlich willkommen
wir laufen uns warm für das große duell
heute abend zur bundestagswahl hier im
zdf in einer halben stunde geht es los
wir streamen das komplette tree l und
gehen danach mit ihnen und euch zu hause
in die analyse und werfen jetzt erst mal
einen schnellen blick nach berlin dort
sehen wir das studio in berlin adlershof
alles schon vorbereitet die
kandidatinnen und die kandidaten wurden
bereits ausgeleuchtet alle sind schon da
und jetzt sind wir sehr gespannt was uns
heute abend erwartet
nicht nur die kandidatin und die
kandidaten sind schon da sondern auch
unsere reporterin alissa jung ist vor
ort alisa beschreibt uns die stimmung
auf einer skala von eins bis zehn wie
hoch ist die anspannung noch
ist es hier relativ ruhig aber es ist ja
jetzt auch wirklich noch ein paar
minuten hinauf bis nach ist zeit eben
gerade warm war ich vor dem pressezelt
also jetzt gerade hier bin ich einem
pressezelt da können also die menschen
die die parteien mitgebracht haben und
auch journalisten und journalisten
können hier also das trail verfolgen
aber eben gerade da war ich also vor dem
studio weil da sind die kandidatinnen
und kandidaten angekommen und da war die
stimmung dann doch schon ein bisschen
aufgeregter als wir hier gerade hier
drin wir haben glaube ich die bilder von
dieser vorfahrt von den vorfahren die
können wir hoffentlich gleich zeigen und
alica kannst du beschreiben wie die
stimmung da war du hast gesagt es sind
ein paar fans auch da um ihren
kandidaten zuzujubeln wie war dieser
moment als die kandidaten gekommen sind
für jede partei hat ihre fans dabei und
haben sich da versammelt die haben still
da die haben plakate und haben wir
versucht auch ordentlich stimmung zu
machen und vor allem sich auch zu
übertönen mit sprechchören als
allererstes kam annalena baerbock von
den grünen an in einem großen bus und
das ausgestiegen und was ganz
interessant war sie war jetzt auch die
einzige von den drei kandidaten zu den
anderen beiden komme ich gleich noch die
also auch zu den fans der anderen
parteien gegangen ist zur spd ist sie
hingegangen und da hatte sie sich auch
mit jemand unter man hatte da nämlich
gesagt wir kriegen das hin also mit wir
kriegen das hin dass man so eine kurze
unterhaltung meinte sie natürlich die
grünen und in dem fall in die spd
könnten ja also die union schlagen das
war dieser dieses gespräch was da
stattgefunden hat und zur union zu den
fans ist sie aber auch gegangen denn die
haben einen sprechchor gerufen und zwar
haben die gesagt berbalk wir wissen was
dein auto tankt das hat er sie akustisch
nicht verstanden da hat sie noch mal
nachgefragt also da gab es auch
interaktionen mit den fans der anderen
beiden parteien und dann danach kam
armin laschet an der kam normal mit
einem auto vorgefahren jetzt nicht mit
einem bus und wurde wer sehr lautstark
von seinen fans das waren sehr sehr
viele wurde er empfangen mit sprechchor
amin amin amin also da war viel stimmung
und auch musik und dann kam als letzter
kam urlaubs und auch da waren natürlich
die stimmung super große haben versucht
auf die fans natürlich ganz viel
stimmung zu machen lauter zu sein als
die anderen also vor der tür war gute
stimmung haben sich feiern lassen von
jungen fans aber auch verschiedene
altersgruppen waren da auch kinder habe
ich gesehen und jetzt hier drinnen im
pressezelt ist natürlich ein bisschen
eine angespannte stimmung und alle sind
ein bisschen aufgeregt was da jetzt
passiert natürlich wie sich die drei
schlagen werden alissa wir freuen uns
dass unsere zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
auch mitmachen können an der stelle noch
mal aktiv der aufruf schreibt uns ihre
und eure kommentare wie immer in die
kommentare oder an die eingeblendete e
mail adresse wenn ihr die zdf- heute-
app nutzt alissa die große frage ist
natürlich an diesem abend wie wird es
armin laschet gelingen den trend noch
mal zu wenden punkte zu sammeln markus
söder hat gesagt dass es das wochenende
an dem es darum geht den trend noch mal
zu ändern was wirst du so unter den
journalistinnen vor ort wie ist die
stimmung wie es die erwartung
also sehr unterschiedlich es gibt schon
also einige die jetzt natürlich sagen
das ist jetzt hier nochmal ganz ganz
wichtig vielleicht das wichtigste event
noch mal bevor es in zwei wochen ja
wirklich dann gewählt wird und auch kein
zurück mehr gibt also das sind jetzt
viele sehr gespannt kommt auch noch mal
vielleicht was überraschendes hat da
vielleicht ein kandidat eine kandidatin
auch noch was auf dem tisch jugend
irgendwas überraschendes was zuvor noch
nicht kam also ich glaube die wenigsten
wissen müsste jetzt heute so passiert
man man fragt sich natürlich also wie
versucht er jetzt noch einmal jeder
einzelnen zu punkten wie versucht
natürlich auch armin laschet dann jetzt
noch einmal zu punkten aber natürlich
die anderen beiden ganz genauso aber ich
glaube wirklich es ist noch sehr viel
wie eine wundertüte und viele sind sehr
gespannt was da jetzt heute passiert
weißt du wo die kandidaten und die
kandidatin gerade sind also ich nehme
nicht an dass hierzu dritter wegen der
couch sitzen und chips essen aber gab es
da schon vorher irgendwie kontakt sind
die sich auf dem flur begegnet sind die
weit auseinander setzen die jetzt
nochmal mit ihren teams zusammen und
besprechen letzte taktiken oder wo sind
sie jetzt gerade
sie kamen nacheinander an da gab es also
keine begegnungen da hat man auch genau
darauf geachtet dass wir also genau
getaktet dass da jeder auf seinen moment
ihren moment natürlich hat um daran zu
kommen und beklatscht zu werden und dann
sind sie also nacheinander in das studio
was ein bisschen jetzt hier hinter dem
presseraum im prinzip liegt das ist also
getrennt voneinander sind sie auf dem
weg ins studio und da kann es natürlich
durchaus sein dass sie sich auch vor dem
studio noch mal begegnen wir dürfen da
jetzt hier nicht dabei sein das ist also
nur ein kleiner kreis der dann da auch
wirklich im studio mit dabei sein darf
hier in diesem zelt das wurde dafür
geschaffen dass man das tri elz war auch
irgendwie miterleben kann aber dann doch
ein wenig mit abstand vielleicht dass es
ja auch noch mal interessant das ist
jetzt hier auch eine wahl in deutschland
in corona zeiten eine bundestagswahl zum
allerersten mal also gibt es natürlich
hier auch gewisse regeln also hier auch
im zelt gilt natürlich entweder ist man
geimpft genesen oder getestet auch nur
hier am tisch habe ich jetzt die maske
trage ich sie jetzt gerade nicht davor
draußen habe ich sie auch auf gehabt und
insofern also jetzt gerade in diesem
moment bin ich nicht dabei während die
kandidaten sich vielleicht noch mal
begegnen oder nicht ab das ist schon
jetzt hier getrennt voneinander aber das
ist natürlich durchaus möglich dass es
da noch mal zu einer begegnung kommt
vielen dank alisa für diese ersten sehr
spannenden eindrücke direkt von vor ort
und wir sind nachher nach dem trial
wieder bei dir um zu erfahren wie die
kandidatinnen und ihre teams denn so
zufrieden sind mit sich selbst und dem
was sie geleistet haben und wir möchten
noch jemand anderen mit in die runde
nehmen heute abend das ist mirko
drotschmann vielen bekannt als mister
wissen to go von youtube hallo mirco
vielen dank dass du bei uns in der
sendung dabei bist du hast ja auch viel
in der vorbereitung für diese
bundestagswahl auch schon sendungen
gemachte auf youtube was ist denn dein
seine erwartungshaltung heute abend
hallo erstmal erst gab ja schon ein tri
l vor zwei wochen und meine
erwartungshaltung ist die dass sich das
was wir da erlebt haben in gewisser
weise wiederholt wir haben erlebt dass
armin laschet angriffslustig war
annalena baerbock fakten geliefert hat
oder versucht hat fakten zu liefern olaf
scholz in der defensive sehr
zurückgehalten hat und ich glaube dass
das ungefähr die konstellation war die
wir auch jetzt erleben werden olaf
scholz ist er derjenige der das feld
anführt dementsprechend du kann er auch
erst mal vielleicht nur zuschauen ich
denke zum beispiel nicht dass er auf
angriff schalten wird ich denke wir
werden da eine kleine wiederholung
erleben ich gucke hier gerade mal in die
kommenden kommentare elke margareta
schreibt über facebook meine wahl ist
bereits im postkasten daumen hoch wir
fragen natürlich nicht was sie gewählt
hat aber sie hat gewählt und das ist
natürlich sehr gut und damit ist sie
wahrscheinlich nicht alleine denn viele
menschen machen ja gerade wegen corona
dieses jahr briefwahl und jetzt zwei
wochen vor der wahl ist natürlich auch
was die briefwahl angeht und
entscheidender moment weil viele werden
heute abend vielleicht noch mal gucken
wie es läuft und danach ihr kreuzchen
machen oder
ja das denke ich auch man hat ja noch
ein bisschen zeit auch wenn man per
brief fehlt ich habe übrigens auch per
brief gewählt das habe ich diese woche
gemacht und ich glaube schon dass
bewusst viele leute warten was passiert
jetzt hier bei diesen tree l noch und
sich danach dann entscheiden insofern
könnte das jetzt schon den ausschlag
geben bei dem einen oder der anderen wo
man dann letztendlich das kreuz macht
und ich bin letztendlich auch gespannt
auf die quoten morgen wie viele leute
eingeschaltet haben beim ersten trial
waren es ja nicht wenige leute aber
weniger als vor vier jahren beim gab es
ja nur eins beim kanzlerduell damals
also wird sicherlich für den einen oder
die anderen ausschlag geben heute und es
ist ja echt ein spannendes rennen wir
gucken uns die zahl nochmal an ihr habt
auch ein politbarometer to go gemacht
auf youtube und die schauen noch mal
gerade wir haben die grafik vorliegen
die sonntagsfrage wenn jetzt schon am
sonntag gewählt würde dann ich hoffe wir
haben uns da ansonsten würde ich vor
lesen weil ich ahne ich hab's
aufgeschrieben aber wunderbar jetzt
können jetzt alle auch sehen wenn am
sonntag bundestagswahl wäre dann käme
die union auf 22 prozent die spd auf 25
die afg auf 11 die fdp auch auf 11 die
singen linke auf 6 die grünen auf 17 die
freien wähler auf 3 und die anderen auf
5 prozent das bedeutet mirco dieser
abend wird besonders für armin laschet
eine herausforderung ihr habt selber
auch viele interviews gemacht auch für
funk und auch mit der cdu und da ist
aber interessanterweise nicht ins spiel
gekommen nicht der spitzenkandidat
gekommen also nicht armin laschet
bekommen sondern jens spahn wenn es doch
um so viel geht und wenn das rennen so
eng ist warum war denn armin laschet
nicht bei euch
das hätten wir auch gerne gewusst eine
eindeutige antwort haben wir darauf
nicht bekommen ihren sparen meinte
sinngemäß zu uns armin laschet hätte
eben viele termine und können nicht
alles wahrnehmen zur ehrenrettung der
union muss man aber sagen es gab diese
video interviews von denen ich zwei
geführt habe mit ihren sparen und das
andere mit christian lindner und es gab
aber auch noch podcast interviews der
kollegin eva schulz und sie hat
tatsächlich mit armin laschet gesprochen
und auch mit olaf chance und annalena
baerbock insofern kann man sagen haben
sie sich vielleicht da aufgeteilt
ähnlich übrigens wie die grünen da waren
für die video interviews robert habeck
dabei und bei dem podcast war es
annalena baerbock insofern war er nicht
der einzige der uns nicht besucht hat
ich fand es sehr schade ich hätte sehr
gerne mit armin laschet gesprochen vor
allem weil man gar nicht weiß wie geht
es mit ihren spar nach der wahl weiter
auch wenn er quasi im tandem mit armin
laschet antritt aber ja da gab es wohl
gründe die uns nicht ganz genau
erläutert wurden dann schauen wir noch
mal auf die beliebtheit der kandidatin
und der kandidaten auch da hat die
forschungsgruppe wahlen gefragt wen
hätten sie denn am liebsten als
bundeskanzler bundeskanzlerin und hier
sehen wir ganz interessant auch die
verläufe seit juni bis jetzt und wir
sehen dass annalena baerbock hier im
verlauf im leichten sinkflug sich
befindet 16 prozent hätten sie gerne als
kanzlerin für armin laschet geht seit
mitte juli bergab 21 prozent wünschen
ihn sich nur als kanzler und für olaf
scholz gehzeit mitte juli bergauf 48
prozent sagen das soll unser kanzler
sein das ist eine trendwende die sich da
in den letzten wochen abgezeichnet hat
er hat die dich überrascht und womit
kannst du das erklären ein stück weit
überraschend war es schon olaf scholz
war ja lange zeit genauso wie die spd
bei vielen abgeschrieben hatte gar nicht
mehr damit gerechnet dass er überhaupt
in irgendeiner form zurückkommt ich
glaube es hat vor allem zwei gründe der
erste grund ist der dass eben olaf
scholz und die spd in den umfragen auch
vor sechs von neun monaten ziemlich weit
hinten lag so dass sich die politischen
kontrahenten ziemlich schnell
eingeschossen haben da war klar okay
entweder armin laschet oder annalena
baerbock entweder die union oder die
grünen stellen den kanzler und olaf
scholz ist so ein bisschen hinten
runtergefallen das heißt kritische
berichterstattung aber auch generell
diskussionen im netz und das augenmerk
das lag vor allem auf laschet und
berbalk und olaf scholz konnte einfach
nur zu gucken wie die beiden
probleme bekommen haben und sich selber
auch probleme geschaffen haben und ich
glaube bei armin laschet gab es dann
auch ganz speziell ein fall der dafür
gesorgt hat dass er in den
beliebtheitswerten abschmiert nämlich
sein lachen während der rede von frank
walter steinmeier der zu den flug
flutopfern gesprochen hat und an die
latte stand im hintergrund die bilder
haben alle gesehen denke ich mal und das
ist ja auch der punkt an dem seine
beliebtheitswerte stark abnehmen bei
annalena baerbock gab es auch einige ich
nenne es mal pannen vorsichtig gesagt da
gab es das buch da gab es die erst spät
gemeldeten sonder einkünfte die sie
hatten und andere dinge und olaf scholz
na ja da hätte auch der nato oder
anderen skandal zu bieten eventuell mit
comics mit wirecard aber das war nicht
so im fokus und ich glaube dass diese
dinge also dass olaf scholz lange der
underdog war auf der einen seite und auf
der anderen seite dass besonders die
anderen im fokus standen dazu
beigetragen haben dass olaf scholz und
die spd jetzt lange aufgeholt haben die
spd sei es wird wahrscheinlich sagen na
ja wir waren die die als erstes im
programm hatten als erste einen
spitzenkandidaten und wir konnten alles
behutsam aufbauen aber ich glaube das
ist eher ein zweitrangiger grund mirko
drotschmann ist da wissen zu go vielen
dank für den moment du bleibst den abend
über bei uns in der sendung und nach dem
trial hören und sehen wir uns dann noch
mal wieder in der analyse an dieser
stelle nochmal ein blick in die
kommentare martin sassen befragt über
facebook kann man hier fragen für das
tri erstellen oder stehen die fragen
schon fest lieber herr sassenberg sie
können hier alle fragen stellen die sie
wollen zum tree l aber leider geraten
sie nicht in street selber das macht die
kollegin maybrit illner und der kollege
von der ard in diesem fall ohne
zuschauerbeteiligung aber es gibt
natürlich rund um die wahl viele formate
die wahlarena zum beispiel auch wo man
fragen stellen kann aber das trio heute
dem fall leider nicht aber wie gesagt
hier bei uns in der sendung gerne über
die kommentare tja das tv-duell zu dritt
sozusagen das erstmals wir hatten es ja
schon vor zwei wochen in rtl aber
erstmals in der deutschen
fernsehgeschichte jetzt auch in ard und
zdf ausgestrahlt wird ist natürlich
insofern sehr interessant als wir seit
1960 tv-duelle kennen damals aus amerika
nixon gegen kennedy und damals haben
viele gemeint dass kennedy gewonnen hat
weil nixon verschwitzt gewirkt hat
unrasiert gewirkt hat unsortiert aber
meinungsforscher sagen heute es geht gar
nicht so sehr um äußerlichkeiten auch
damals schon nicht es geht um viel mehr
insofern sind wir sehr gespannt welche
dinge heute den ausschlag geben wer
heute abend punkten kann und aus
gegebenem anlass bringt aus gegebenem
anlass bringt sarah alaska uns nochmal
up to date was vergangene tv duelle in
deutschland angeht
2002 ging es los kanzler schröder gegen
herausforderer stoiber auf großer bühne
der erste fernseh schlagabtausch
abgeschlagen nach der wahl stoiber
schröder weiter im amt
2005 erster duell auftritt angela merkel
sie denken von tag zu tag und das
meistens noch im zickzack kurs und
merkel damit konsolen zweite sie kam
weiter wurde kanzlerin vier jahre später
steinmeier will merkel das amt abjagen
eine bessere alternative gibt nämlich
mich der wahlausgang bekannt
2013 hieß die alternative peer
steinbrück verspreche nichts vollmundig
was ich nicht halten kann im kanzleramt
blieb merkel
2017 versuchte es dann martin schulz wir
sind verliebt ins geblieben aber nicht
ins scheitern
gescheitert ist er trotzdem
der schlagabtausch heute er wird anders
sein nach 16 jahren erstmals ohne merkel
und statt einem duell entry l
ja das in einer knappen viertelstunde
losgeht schack und aller banerjee ist
uns zugeschaltet unsere hauptstadt
korrespondent in punta ala wer die
biografie von barack obama gelesen hat
weiß dass er manchmal eminem gehört hat
oder andere playlist vor bestimmten
auftritten oder wahlkampfreden weißt du
etwas darüber wie sich denn die
kandidaten und die kandidatin auf dieses
trient vorbereitet haben
denn niemand ich habe es hier gerade
eben noch mal versucht wir hoffen sehr
sehr viele mitglieder der parteien und
auch enge berater der kandidatinnen und
kandidaten rum aber ein bisschen was
konnte ich tatsächlich raus finden und
das zeigt auch schon wie unterschiedlich
die typen sind wir unterschiedlich die
ausgangslage ist die sprecherin der
grünen sagte mir zum beispiel annalena
baerbock habe sich in den vergangenen
tagen intensiv auf dieses trio
vorbereitet auch aus dem umfeld von
armin laschet hört man dass es heute
nochmal in kleiner runde eine
konzentrierte vorbereitung gegeben habe
auf diesen termin hier nur aus dem
umfeld von olaf scholz klingt das ein
wenig anders er habe heute keine
weiteren termine gehabt also sich er
entspannen können so unterschiedlich
sind da die gemüter aber vielleicht auch
die herausforderungen
und christian reek fragt über facebook
es werden parteien gewählt keine figuren
warum ist dieses tree l denn trotzdem so
wichtig heute abend
ja das stimmt natürlich wir wählen
natürlich nicht den kanzlerin oder den
kanzler direkt allerdings ist die
position des kanzlers oder der kanzlerin
ja am ende eine herausgehoben diese
personen die dann im kanzleramt sitzt
hat die richtlinienkompetenz hätte also
theoretisch auch das recht wenn es mal
im kabinett keine einigung gibt zu sagen
hier geht's lang oder da geht's lang und
dann ist es natürlich interessant für
alle wählerinnen und wähler zu sehen
welche vorstellungen haben diejenigen
die sich um das amt bewerben und man
bekommt natürlich auch ein gespür dafür
welche positionen diejenigen die drei
die wir heute abend hören werden frey
vertreten können und an welcher stelle
sie vielleicht auch zurückgehalten
werden von bestimmten beschlüssen ihrer
eigenen parteien von bestimmten
vorstellungen ihrer anhängerschaft also
das sind so die dinge die man zum teil
zwischen den zeilen herauslesen muss zum
teil aber vielleicht auch mal als klare
antwort bekommen
santala wie hoch ist der druck auf die
drei heute abend
der ist schon erheblich also man sieht
ja momentan dass die umfragen sehr
volatil sind das heißt sie gehen mal
rauf mal runter je nachdem welches
umfrageinstitut man hat es gibt viele
unentschlossene wählerinnen und wähler
die noch bis ich bis zum ende
wahrscheinlich überlegen werden wählen
sie die stimme geben möchten und das
bedeutet jeder einzelne auftritt auf dem
die kandidatinnen und kandidaten sich
noch mal vorstellen können ist natürlich
jetzt besonders viel wert und es gab
schon 1 tl
bei dem man genau hingeschaut hat bei
dem natürlich nicht alle themen
abgedeckt werden konnten jetzt sind wir
nur noch zwei wochen vor der
bundestagswahl das ist ein besonderer
moment denn früher hieß es immer zwei
wochen das ist die allerletzte heiße
wahlkampfphase da kann man noch mal
menschen erreichen die vorher vielleicht
noch nicht überzeugt waren die
vielleicht etwas anderes wählen wollte
man kann auch noch mal die eigenen
anhänger mobilisieren das hören wir
jetzt zum beispiel aus der union dass da
ganz kräftig getrommelt wird und
vielleicht diejenigen die nach der
langen zeit der pandemie und auch nach
den nach dem ein oder anderen vorfall
stichwort masken dir gesagt haben ich
habe immer union gewählt ich bin mir
jetzt nicht so sicher will ich es machen
die zu motivieren auf jeden fall zur
wahl zu gehen und dann aus unionssicht
natürlich dann cdu zu wählen also das
sind tatsächlich noch mal ist ein moment
wo man noch mal ein bisschen schub
reinbringen kann ob sie jetzt
tatsächlich am ende allein an einer
solchen
tv-diskussion liegt das
danke schön stark und allah und bevor
wir hier im studio weiterreden werfen
wir noch mal ganz schnell einen blick
ins studio in berlin um zu sehen wie es
dort aussieht das ist nicht das studio
war das ist das was sie gleich sehen
werden wenn die sendungen los geht das
tri l der dreikampf ums kanzleramt und
in knapp zehn minuten geht es los um
viertel nach acht und wir sind natürlich
live dabei
bis dahin nutzen wir die zeit und
begrüßen hier im studio professor jürgen
meyer von der universität koblenz-landau
sein fachgebiet ist politische
kommunikation und herr professor meyer
sie haben eine app entwickelt die quasi
auch sie zu hause ihr zuhause jetzt
nutzen können um in echtzeit
quasi ein feedback zu geben wie das tri
l und wie die kandidatinnen im einzelnen
so ankommen herr professor meyer können
sie erklären wie die app funktioniert ja
also erstmal vielen dank für die
einladung freue mich heute abend hier zu
sein wir haben eine app
entwickelt gemeinsam mit der tu
kaiserslautern deutschen
forschungszentrum für künstliche
intelligenz dfk ebenfalls in
kaiserslautern und diese app hat im
prinzip zwei bestandteile das erste ist
es gibt eine fragebogen einheit da
werden fragen zu den kandidaten zu den
eigenen politischen präferenzen und
ähnliches gestellt vor und nach dem
duell und auf der anderen seite hat man
tatsächlich die möglichkeit
wären das
der debatte ist kein duell sondern 3 l
die kandidaten und auch die moderatoren
in echtzeit zu bewerten also tatsächlich
auf einem schieberegler
anzugeben was man gerade von den von dem
sprecher der das wort hat hält auf einer
skala von minus drei bis plus drei wir
können das hier gerade mal zeigen auf
dem monitor hinter mir müsste man es
jetzt sehen genau hier sieht man
echtzeit messungen da wird noch mal
erklärt
wie die ausgangslage ist und dass die
urteile im sekundentakt gespeichert
werden ich klicke jetzt mal auf weiter
okay jetzt wird noch mal ein bisschen
erklärt wie es funktioniert ja
ich erlaube das bei nutzung der app und
so weiter erst mal alles sie sagen stopp
wenn ich hier was überspringen was was
sehr wichtig ist so genau und das ist
jetzt die skala von der sie gesprochen
haben genau
so sieht das aus während dieser debatte
die instruktion oder die idee ist dass
man gerade denjenigen bewertet der
spricht das ist der situation geschuldet
dass wir eben drei kandidaten haben und
ja es etwas schwierig ist mit drei
kandidaten und drei reglern oder eingabe
einheiten trotzdem geht er nicht genau
sie können das hohle sind rhein-main
genau das denn die maximalwerte +3
bedeutet man hat einen außerordentlich
guten eindruck von demjenigen oder
derjenigen die gerade spricht - drei
genau das gegenteil und man kann das
stufenlos eben einstellen sie haben das
auch schon gemacht bei den beim letzten
und sie haben auch schon vorher bei
anderen duellen solche arten von
messungen gemacht welche momente sind
denn da besonders interessant gewesen
aber wir machen das seit 2002 gar sind
sozusagen seit dem ersten
dabei gewesen
2013 haben wir zum ersten mal die
möglichkeit entwickelt dass man das von
zu hause aus machen konnte 2017 erneut
und wie sie richtig sagen waren wir beim
ersten trial auch dabei
ja es ist sozusagen die gesamtheit der
kandidaten ist ein paket was da
überzeugen muss auf der einen seite
natürlich die inhalte die sie
transportieren
das was sie sagen aber es geht natürlich
auch darum wie etwas gesagt wird welche
strategie eigentlich gewählt wird auch
mit der frage was will ich eigentlich
erreichen möchte ich meine eigenen
wähler in irgendeiner art mobilisieren
oder möchte ich irgendwie auf die immer
noch hohe zahl von unentschiedenen
möchte ich die anvisieren und gerade so
und real hat er unglaublich
komplexe gemengelage von daher ist das
für die kandidaten gar nicht einfach
also inhalte auf der einen seite
strategie auf der anderen seite aber wie
die kolleginnen auch schon im interview
gesagt es geht auch um die
persönlichkeit der kandidaten dort einen
eindruck zu entwickeln gerade in einer
situation
wo man die kandidaten und die kandidatin
gerade nicht so wahnsinnig gut kennt
weil es keine amtsinhaber gibt könnte
das vielleicht auch ein entscheidender
moment auch da können wir gerade mal
gucken wir haben eine grafik hier
vorliegen sie haben gerade die strategie
angesprochen wenn man mal kurz auf das
laptop hier schaltet dann sieht man
wahrgenommene debatten strategie der
kanzlerkandidaten berbalk in grünland in
schwarz und scholz in rot und da haben
die leute die mitgemacht haben das
gefühl gehabt dass scholz so gut wie gar
nicht angegriffen hat
ansonsten können sie noch ein bisschen
was zu der grafik da wird ja also das
sind messungen vom ersten trial
wir haben hinterher die teilnehmer
gefragt welchen eindruck sie hatten
bezüglich der strategie der kandidaten
und was ihr völlig richtig ausgeführt
haben ist dass der olaf scholz ein
klassischer amtsinhaber strategie
verwendet hat also sich eigentlich aus
allen konflikten herausgehalten versucht
für seine politik zu werben und ein
bisschen außen vor was wir beobachten
konnten war dass laschet und berbalk ja
scharmützel gehabt haben im prinzip
beide sind als relativ aggressiv
wahrgenommen worden
das hat man für armin laschet vielleicht
nicht unbedingt erwartet weil er hat ja
eigentlich auch eine situation wo er als
amtsinhaber auf erfolge
und und leistung
in seiner politischen karriere verweisen
dann sind wir gespannt was heute abend
welche strategie heute abend verfolgt
wird wir blicken noch mal nach berlin
und können sehen dass alle inzwischen
schon versammelt sind im studio in
adlershof die beiden moderatoren sind da
die kandidaten in der mitte der grünen
rechts sind wir olaf scholz und etwas
rächt sich für armin laschet und links
sehen wir olaf scholz und bis es gleich
in wirklich wenigen minuten los geht
noch mal die frage an dich schack und
allawi wahlentscheidend ist dieser abend
konnte energy in berlin diese kommenden
95 minuten
ich würde es nicht allein an dieses trio
hängen denn tatsächlich merken wir auch
in den an den fragen von zuschauerinnen
und zuschauern dass sich die menschen
sehr für themen interessieren dass sie
wissen wollen was die parteien anbieten
und das lässt sich natürlich in einem
solchen trainer nicht komplett aber ab
arbeiten aber das wird sicherlich
nochmal aussagen darüber geben wie die
kandidaten und kann die kandidatin zum
zu bestimmten themen stehen fragen kann
ich ihnen natürlich noch nicht
beantworten das wird ja gleich die
spannende die überraschung sozusagen
werden womit sie diesmal konfrontiert
werden aber natürlich werden sie alle
auch versuchen nochmal ihre kernthemen
da unterzubringen wo sie es machen
können noch mal deutlich zu punkten und
vor allem ist es natürlich auch eine
frage wie souverän man aus so einem
gespräch hervor geht dann natürlich
werden alle am ende fragen wer hat denn
jetzt am meisten überzeugt da gehen die
meinungen dann je nach anhängerschaft
alles sehr auseinander wir können davon
ausgehen dass hier in diesem zelt wo
sich sehr viele parteimitglieder und
berater der drei befinden und am ende
alle sagen werden dass ihre kandidatin
ihr kandidat das beste bild abgegeben
haben aber die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer vor den fernsehbildschirmen
die machen sich ja eben auch ihre eigene
bilden sie sich ihre eigene meinung
genau und das waren sie in wenigen
sekunden stoffen theologie des einen
schrank und deshalb geben wir ab nach
berlin adlershof und sind sehr gespannt
bis nachher gute unterhaltung
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer herzlich
willkommen zum dreikampf der
spitzenkandidaten bei ard und zdf einen
schönen guten abend in den nächsten 95
minuten wollen wir zentrale probleme
dieses landes besprechen und die frage
stellen wie diese drei die probleme
lösen wollen als kanzlerin oder als
kanzler guten abend annalena baerbock
guten armin laschet und einen guten
abend olaf scholz die moderatoren sind
gespannt wir werden darauf achten dass
die rede anteile unter ihnen
einigermaßen fair verteilt sind und wir
sagen auch noch dass alle menschen hier
in diesem studio negativ getestet oder
geimpft sind und schon geht's los genau
und zwar mit der ersten frage an armin
laschet nach allen umfragen liegen sie
im augenblick hinter der spd jetzt
werden sie dafür kämpfen in den nächsten
14 tagen als erster ins ziel zu kommen
aber wenn das nicht gelingen sollte
würden sie auch als juniorpartner in
eine regierung scholz eintreten also als
erstes wollen wir jetzt die nächsten
wochen kämpfen das ist das ziel das ist
ja auch die idee dieses tri ace dass die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer draußen
sich noch einmal ein bild verschaffen
können wer steht für welche position und
das ist das was wir jetzt vor unter und
die frage war aber ob sie in regierungs
scholz einziger nicht beantwortet wie
sie gesehen haben sondern wir sind nicht
bei regierungsbildungen sondern wir sind
beim werben um den richtigen weg für
unser land was steht jetzt an und ich
finde wir haben nach der wahl noch so
viel zeit zu sehen wer mit wem wiegen
koaliert jetzt ist die zeit eigene
argumente zu nennen und das will ich
heute die zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
würde es aber trotzdem interessieren und
ich kann sie nicht zwingend zu antworten
aber den zuschauerinnen und zuschauern
sagen sie wollen die frage nicht
beantworten also eines ist klar für uns
wir werden auf keinen fall mit der
linken koalieren wir werden auf keinen
fall mit der afg koalieren wir werden
mit denen nicht mal reden wir werden
nicht kooperieren und demokraten
untereinander müssen nach der wahl reden
und wir kämpfen um platz eins und damit
sind wir bei annalena baerbock sie
merken schon wir fragen nach politischen
vorlieben und nach politischen grenzen
sie haben schon angekündigt dass sie
gerne mit olaf scholz eine
regierungsbündnis eingehen indem für rot
grün reicht es momentan nicht tendieren
sie eher zu fdp oder tendieren sie sie
zu den linken bei der fdp wäre klar dass
sie eigentlich alle sozialen punkte
ihres programms plus klimaschutz nicht
gut durchsetzen können erst meinen
schönen guten abend durch kreative
derzeit zu keiner der beiden varianten
sondern ich kämpfe mit voller
leidenschaft für den echten aufbruch die
wahl die jetzt jahr ansteht in knapp
zwei wochen ist machen wir ein weiter so
der großen koalition oder schaffen wir
echten aufbruch und der geht nur mit
starken grünen der geht nur mit grün in
führender rolle und dafür kämpfe ich
gerade die großen themen klimaschutz
digitalisierung stehen die kommunen das
ist was wir jetzt eine veränderung im
land stehen die grünen gerade nicht so
gut da es gab mal ein schwarz grünes
projekt daran sei erinnert und beide
parteien haben momentan zu kämpfen noch
mal die frage es geht nur ein dreier
bündnis würden sie sagen mit der
linkspartei können wir viele unserer
punkte von den mieten bis sie zum
klimaschutz viel besser umsetzen sie
haben nicht diesen bündnis ausschluss
partei vertreibt dieses bündnis aus 2013
ein bündnis paragrafen
parteitagsbeschluss abgeschlossen wie
die spd und sagen trotzdem dass sie sich
das mit der linken vorstellen können
oder könnten sie sich nicht mit der
linken vor ich habe mich in den letzten
tagen dazu sehr klar geäußert dass wir
eine wirkliche veränderung brauchen eine
veränderung bedeutet das ding auch
wirklich anders gemacht werden deswegen
kämpfe ich auch wenn uns ein paar
prozentpunkte noch nach oben fehlen für
den führung unter einer grünen regierung
wir haben die meisten schnittmengen
gerade im see jahren links beim sozialen
bereich mit der spd mit der linkspartei
auch das habe ich ja mehrfach deutlich
gemacht ich bin von herzen pro
europäerin ich bin davon überzeugt die
nächste bundesregierung muss eine aktive
außenpolitik betreiben sich nicht
wegducken und die linke hat mit der
letzten entscheidung auch mit blick auf
afghanistan deutlich gemacht dass sie
diese internationale verantwortung nicht
tragen will aber wir haben den letzten
jahren auch in unserem land gesehen wie
brandgefährlich es ist wenn
demokratische parteien nicht miteinander
reden und deswegen sage ich hier klar
und deutlich wir reden mit allen
demokratischen parteien aber wer braucht
die linke ist die linke eine
demokratische partei oder ist sie halb
demokratischere sie für dieses land
genauso gefährlich wie die afd auf gar
keinen fall und diese gleichsetzung von
afg mit linker halte ich für
brandgefährlich vor allen dingen weil
man dann absolut verharmlost das jahr
auf den nicht auf dem boden des
grundgesetzes steht wir erleben dass
immer wieder im deutschen bundestag wir
koalieren mit der linken in einigen
bundesländern auch deswegen hat
selbstverständlich ist eine
demokratische partei aber wir haben in
der außenpolitik wir haben auch mit
blick auf die innenpolitik innere
sicherheit verfassungsschutz große
differenzen auch mit der linken aber
noch mal wir sind jetzt kurz vor der
oper la da fällt schon der studios haben
will will ich kurz vor der bundesbank
aber ist noch wie es gerade hier rumpelt
im studio so spannend wird diese
bundestagswahl ich glaube es war in den
letzten jahrzehnten noch nie so spannend
wir hatten das schon mal als damals rot
grün gewählt worden ist
2002 da war es auch bis zur letzten
woche reichte es eigentlich nicht für
dieses zweierbündnis und deswegen gebe
ich jetzt alles weil ich bin zutiefst
davon überzeugt deutschland kann mehr
und wir brauchen jetzt den aufdruck
koalieren auch in mehreren bundesländern
mit der linken warum schließen sie aber
eine koalition mit der linken auf
bundesebene wo es wie frau berbalk hat
es angesprochen ja auch um andere themen
geht auch um aussenpolitik ein solches
bündnis dort nicht auf naja ich meine
wir leben ja jetzt immer absurdere
theateraufführung vor kurzem wurde
lindner aufgefordert auszuschließen dass
er mit der spd und den grünen koaliert
das hat irgendwie vielleicht deutlich
gemacht dass wir auf dem boden der dinge
bleiben sollen die bürgerinnen und
bürger entscheiden wie die wahl ausgeht
ich werbe um ein sehr sehr starkes
mandat für die spd das finde ich wichtig
dass gibt die grundlage dafür dass man
eine gute regierung bilden kann und all
die grundsätze verfolgen die mir wichtig
sind und das ist klar wer in deutschland
regieren will muss klare positionen
haben er muss sich bekennen zur
transatlantischen zusammenarbeit man
muss klar sagen dass die nato für unsere
sicherheit unverzichtbar ist und dass
wir unsere verpflichtungen im bündnis
erfüllen müssen er muss sich klar zu
einer starken souverän europäischen
union bekennen und das will ich auch
sagen da gehört natürlich gerade auch
jetzt wo die zeiten so schwierig sind
will ich das sagen zu dass man auch in
der lage sein muss entscheidungen zu
treffen die zum beispiel bedeuten dass
deutsche soldaten an dann ländern zum
beispiel im rahmen eines eu mandats im
rahmen eines mandats der vereinten
nationen oder der nato tätig sind dass
hier auch weiter sind so innovativ mit
denen sie über die mit der linken
sprechen würden ich bin klar in den
grundsätzen jeder der mich kennt weiß
was er kriegt und ich werde mich entlang
dieser grundsätze verhalten und deshalb
ist es jetzt erst mal wichtig dass die
bürgerinnen bürger ihre entscheidung
treffen und die möglichkeiten nutzen
diese damit haben umso besser dass man
dafür die spd ausfällt umso mehr möglich
machen dass sich der nächste
regierungschef werde umso besser wird es
auch gelingen eine gute regierung zu
schaffen habe ich zu der frage
vielleicht nur kurz sagen das ist ein
wenig unredlich herr scholz zu sagen das
entscheiden die bürgerinnen und bürger
ja die bürgerinnen und bürger werden ein
wahlergebnis uns bescheren danach stehen
wir in der verantwortung zu sagen was
bilden wir für eine regierung für
deutschland und man muss ihnen die frage
gar nicht stellen ob sie mit der linken
koalieren würden weil sie haben sie ja
schon beantwortet sie schließen das
nicht aus wir haben die
bundestagsdebatte diese woche erlebt er
bartsch von der linken hat gesagt ihr
müsst doch bei uns sein lieber die linke
als christian lindner in ihren
programmen sind sie in vielem ähnlich
bei steuererhöhungen und bei vielem
anderen mehr und in ihrer fraktion war
zu sehen dass viele zustimmend genickt
manche sogar geklatscht haben und
deshalb muss jedem klar sein wenn es
eine rechnerische mehrheit gibt selbst
wenn sie auf platz zwei liegen als
partei werden sie eine koalition mit den
linken machen dass deshalb glauben die
bürgerinnen und bürger ihnen das nur
wenn sie klipp und klar sagen jemand der
den verfassungsschutz abschaffen will
der senator aus will selbst wenn der
nachher auf einem papier zugestehen
würde ja ich bin vielleicht doch für
eine reformierte nato sie müssen
klarheit haben weil die bürgerinnen und
bürger die linke nicht in einer
bundesregierung haben will dazu waren
sie auch heute nicht bereit und deshalb
ist das schon mal eine klare aussage von
ihnen am heutigen abend mir liegt ein
bisschen daran zu sagen dass ja die
absurden dinge geht doch schon deutlich
geworden sind ich habe eben darauf
verwiesen dass herr söder geforderte
lindner soll das bündnis mit uns beiden
ausschließen und ich habe in der frage
der außen und sicherheitspolitik genauso
wie vor der burg mehr gemeinsamkeiten
mit der fdp als mit der partei über die
sie jetzt gesprochen haben aber was
nicht funktioniert ist dass man die
bürgern und bürger praktisch nicht mehr
beteiligt an den entscheidungen wenn es
nach einigen gegangen wäre dann wäre
schon vor ein paar monaten klar gewesen
wie die bundestagswahl ausgegangen wäre
man hätte sich nur noch über das
hinterher unterhalten müssen aber
tatsächlich ist das doch ein ganz großer
demokratischer moment ist es der tag der
bürgerinnen und bürger der 26 september
die entscheiden wer der nächste kanzler
wird indem sie ihr kreuz bei der partei
machen die ihn stellen soll aber das ist
auch das warum ist die frage der bürger
und was man mit ihnen erwartet als
kabinett sie haben kein zukunftsteam
vorgestellt sie haben kein
schattenkabinett vorgestellt sie halten
saskia esken für ministrabel unterliegt
die frage auf dem tableau wenn man olaf
scholz wählt bekommt man dann saskia
esken als ministerin man bekommt dann
olaf scholz als bundeskanzler und das
führt auch dazu dass eine regierung
gebildet wird die diesen grundsätzen
entspricht ich will mal ein bisschen
dafür werben dass irgendjemand von ihren
kollegen vielleicht auch einer von ihnen
beiden sie oder sie mal ein buch
lustiges buch schreibt über die
mitglieder von schatten kabinetten die
nix geworden sind das ist ziemlich
ziemlich lang her und ehrlicherweise für
das ja auch dazu dass man dann ab lenkt
von den eigentlichen politischen
debatten ich jedenfalls werde ein
kabinett zusammenstellen das zur hälfte
aus männern und frauen besteht das aus
lauter männern und frauen besteht die
die sache auch gut können und die
zueinander passen und eine gute
regierung für unser land zustande
bringen wollen es ist alles auf sie
zugeschnitten in diesem wahlkampf auf
den spitzenkandidaten olaf scholz wie
gefährlich könnte dann ihre partei und
dem erfolg ihrer partei werden dass es
in ihrem ministerium im
finanzministerium eine razzia gegeben
hat die untersuchung die dort gemacht
worden sind von einer osnabrücker
behörde weil sie verdacht haben dass
möglicherweise in köln 1 bei mitarbeiter
bei der dortigen behörde nicht richtig
gearbeitet hätten die sind zur
unterstützung dieser erkenntnisgewinne
durchgeführt worden und das hat gar
nichts mit den ministerien zu tun wo das
stattgefunden hat die haben aber alles
gemacht was in dieser frage notwendig
ist wenn ich das hier bei der
gelegenheit einmal sagen darf als ich
bundesminister wurde im märz 2018 war
gerade von bundesminister schäuble
organisiert worden das dfg die financial
intelligence unit drüber geht zur zum
toll dass dort die arbeit geleistet wird
die mitunter aufhängen von der straße
aber auch mehr mitarbeiter die mit
aufklärung von all den dingen verbunden
ist mit dem terrorismusfinanzierung und
all diejenigen die dazugehören
und dann habe ich eine behörde
übernommen mit knapp 160 mitarbeitern
die jetzt fast 500 hat die demi 700
mitarbeiter haben wird ich habe dafür
gesorgt dass sie eine moderne it bekommt
eine neue leitung dafür gesorgt dass mit
den ländern und den ministerien
kriterien gemeinsam entwickelt werden
was ausgesucht werden soll und wir haben
alle dazu eingeladen dass sie möglichst
viele meldungen machen dass meldung
aufkommen ist gestiegen von knapp 50.000
auf jetzt fast 150000 das wird auch
weiter steigen aber man
kann
ihnen das abnehmen dass sie damit mir
selbst zu tun haben aber vielleicht
lassen sie mich das mal sagen wir setzen
sogar künstliche intelligenz ein wir
haben jetzt eine unternehmensberatung
beauftragt und diesen ganzen großen
aufbau und modernisierungsprozess einer
vorher ganz klein behörde zu
organisieren zu ende zu bringen und zu
voranzubringen und ich glaube dass das
wirklich ein ganz beeindruckende
leistung ist halt dass auch seine ganz
bei einer leistung also es ist
das ist schon ein wunder wie sie selbst
in diesem fall wenn eine
staatsanwaltschaft in ihr ministerium
kommt und untersuchungen durchführt eine
solche schönrederei an den tag legen
können sie haben die aufsicht über
geldwäsche sie haben diese institution
wir haben übrigens in unserem
wahlprogramm drin weil wir diese
defizite kannten diese institution ins
bundeskriminalamt zu integrieren und
nicht da wo sie jetzt ist und sie sagen
wir haben immer mehr mitarbeiter es wird
aber immer weniger aufgeklärt und es
wird so wenig bei der geldwäsche
aufgeklärt dass ein staatsanwalt sagt
ich brauche hier weitere informationen
und dann ein richter verfügt dass eine
solche durchsuchen stattfinden kann und
deshalb erscholl zwar das unangemessen
dass sie abfällig über die justiz
geredet haben das ist unangemessen das
machen populisten in anderen ländern
wenn die kommen müssen sie sagen hier
ich lege alles offen und denen nicht
vorschreiben wie sie zur arbeit nahm und
wenn es der eine fall jetzt wäre wo sie
keine verantwortung übernehmen wollen
für den nachgeordneten bereich den sie
haben ist es ja nicht der erste fall bei
wirecard haben millionen kleinanleger
viel viel geld verloren weil sie nicht
die aufsicht richtig ausgerichtet haben
die das hätte überprüfen müssen dafür
tragen sie verantwortung ich sie
persönlich weil sie jeden tag da am
schreibtisch sitzen und aufsicht üben
aber als minister haben sie wie jeder
andere fachminister auch dafür zu sorgen
dass die aufsichtsbehörde die es gibt
ihren job macht und wenn nicht haben sie
einzugreifen und wenn sie dazu nicht in
der lage sind also ich sage ihnen wenn
mein finanzminister so arbeiten würde
wie sie hätten wir ein ernstes problem
und der dritte punkt comex da haben
kriminelle geschäfte dazu geführt dass
manche sich zweifach vom staat haben
geld erstatten lassen das ist ein unding
man muss nicht steuern erhöhen man muss
erstmal das geld was da wäre reinholen
und da haben sie in hamburg darauf
verzichtet dieses geld obwohl wolfgang
schäuble sie damals gewarnt hat dass
eine verjährungsfrist eintritt dieses
geld hinein zu holen jetzt wird darüber
gestritten ob sie den bankier getroffen
haben oder nicht kann ich nicht
beurteilen soll der
untersuchungsausschuss klären aber dass
sie an einen punkt einfach mal
verantwortung übernehmen so wie sie es
theoretisch bei dem amt das sie
anstreben machen müssten das kann man
von ihnen erwarten auch als
bundesminister der finanzen robert
machen sie sich diese frage auch zu
eigen
also ich kann jetzt in
staatsanwaltschaftliche ermittlungen
kann man von außen dich sagen was
richtig oder falsch ist dass dafür haben
wir die justiz sei die das überprüft da
haben wir ein klares rechtssystem wie
das vonstatten geht und was für mich
zentrales ist gerade in der situation wo
wir ja nach der korona pandemie in einer
lage sind dass wir viele viele
investitionen in die zukunft machen dass
wir viel viel geld brauchen und eines
der größten probleme auch mit blick auf
den staatshaushalt ist dass dem staat
rund 50 milliarden euro jährlich durch
steuerbetrug durch geldwäsche durch
kriminelle aktivitäten durch die lappen
gehen und jederzeit redlich versteuern
in unserem land der buchladen der kleine
unternehmer die pflegekraft und dass das
thema steuer betrug geldwäsche nicht in
den letzten jahren absolute priorität
hat das fing schon an bei der cdu sie
haben dann ja gesagt sie haben
ausgestoppt an personal auch aufgestockt
aber die drei untergeordneten behörden
des bundes finanzamt überall hat es
heftige probleme gegeben dass
fehlinformation dass die fragen von
kriminellen tätigkeit nicht an die
staatsanwaltschaft weitergegeben wurden
sind und was für mich zentral ist es gab
ja aus dem deutschen bundestag das ist
das herzstück unserer demokratie das
parlament dann immer wieder nachfragen
sollte nicht noch mal personal
eingestellt werden meine fraktion hat
das gefragt da hat ihr haus dann vor
einigen monaten noch gesagt nee brauchen
wir nicht jetzt sehen wir offensichtlich
hat es ein großes problem gegeben ich
frage mich ehrlich gesagt warum auch mit
blick auf diese offene frage mit der
warburg-bank das protokoll des
finanzausschusses von ihrem hause
blockiert wird dass es nicht
veröffentlicht wird oder im traumland of
ethics und den grünen das ist ihr
potenzieller koalitionspartner herr
scholz sie sind dran schönen dank also
die erste aussage die hier machen möchte
ist das ja man sieht wie ein bisschen
dinge verdreht werden und zwar auch in
dem man ganz bewusst verdreht herr
laschet das müssen sie sich vorwerfen
lassen sie klar es hat keine
untersuchung gegeben beim
bundesministerium der finanzen
es ist nicht so dass die
staatsanwaltschaft aus osnabrück
irgendwelche fragen hat bei der
ermittlung gegen dieses ministerium oder
gegen das justizministerium diesem
falschen eindruck haben sie mit absicht
er wird er hat eine durchsuchung in
ihrem audi haben eine absicht die haben
laschet sie haben absichtlich einen
falschen eindruck erweckt und das machen
sie auch nicht guten gründen deshalb
darf es
ein graben heraus durchsucht worden oder
nicht ja guckt so an ihrer frage merkt
man wie sehr sie unehrlich sind und das
ist etwas sehr und innerlich im hause
die staatsanwältin im hause war die
startseite ist doch unter 3 die
staatsanwaltschaft hat eine untersuchung
in köln und für die untersuchung die sie
dort macht braucht sie auskünfte sie hat
keine untersuchung die im hinblick auf
dieses ministerium und weil sie das so
darstellen wecken sie einen falschen
eindruck packen völlig beiseite dass der
größte modernisierungs und aufbauprozess
dieser behörde stattgefunden knapp drei
jahren in denen ich minister bin und
packen noch ein paar andere unwahrheiten
dazu zum beispiel die dass bei wirecard
nicht die notwendigen maßnahmen auf den
weg gebracht worden sind wir haben dafür
gesorgt nachdem die wirtschaftsprüfer
jahrelang geprüft haben und nichts
rausgekriegt haben das jetzt eine
leistungsfähige gesetzesänderung
stattgefunden hat die dazu führt dass
wirtschaftsprüfer häufiger wechseln
müssen wir haben dafür gesorgt dass
prüfung und beratung getrennt werden wir
haben dafür gesorgt dass jetzt die
aufsichtsbehörde viel mehr macht hat als
sie viele viele jahre in deutschland
hatte und die möglichkeiten hat zu
handeln schnell
schon drei jahre zuvor auch
berichterstattung und journalistische
recherche die das nach wie es vielleicht
können bis zu zusammenfassend ganz kurz
herr scholz wie dramatisch oder wie
schwer ist es wenn ausgerechnet ein
sozialdemokrat die beispiele sind
genannt comics wirecard und jetzt diese
razzia in den eindruck entlässt dass er
eben der finanzkriminalität und ihrer
bekämpfung
die aufgaben einfach nicht so ernst
nimmt oder lachs mit ihnen umgeht was
soll das beim steuerzahler auslösen wenn
er sie da agieren sieht ganz einfach
dass er guckt was gemacht worden ist und
die steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler
sind ja sehr klar so etwas wie den
großen aufbau der behörde über die wm
gesprochen hat in dieser zeit nirgendwo
sonst gegeben das gleiche gilt für die
dramatischen entscheidenden veränderung
die ich durchgesetzt hat bei der
wirtschaftsprüfung in deutschland für
die großen kapitalgesellschaften und
alle wissen dass hier an den
verschiedenen vorwürfen sich niemals
herausgestellt hat dass was dran ist und
das ist glaube ich auch ganz wichtig ich
habe das getan was zu tun ist wenn man
ein amt hat es gibt viele kriminelle die
straftaten machen dafür beschuldigt
niemand die polizei und wir müssen als
politiker dafür sorgen dass die polizei
auf wächst was ich in dieser
legislaturperiode beim bka war der
bundespolizei auch übrigens für den zoll
mit organisiert haben und möglich
gemacht habe und für diese behörden über
die wir jetzt sprechen das heißt genau
das was notwendig ist es gemacht worden
und das ist meine leistungsbilanz auf
die es in dieser frage auch sehr stolz
parkett verlassen das gelte wissen dass
jetzt einmal so stehen lassen erläutert
es verstehen lassen weil erstens ich bin
immer in die politik gegangen um redlich
zu argumentieren
ich habe deutlich gemacht dass sie eine
aufsichtspflicht haben und wenn sie
jetzt sagen ja ich habe so viele neue
leute eingestellt und bei wirecard ich
habe dies getan ich habe das getan das
ergebnis ihres tuns ist dass die
aufsicht versagt hat und das millionen
kleinanleger ihr geld verloren an und in
dem sie sagen jeder sitz irgendeine
behörde in köln erwecken sie den
eindruck als wenn sie damit nichts zu
tun hätten darüber haben sie die
fachaufsicht über diese behörde und bei
comex das ist nun offenkundig haben sie
in hamburg versäumt rechtzeitig in der
frist das geld von denen die betrogen
haben ein so auch das ist eine falsche
barak denn auch wir haben jetzt dreimal
die falschen behauptung wiederum sie
keinem auf sicht und ich sage nochmal
wir haben eine aufsicht allerdings nicht
über die einzelentscheidungen das will
ich hier gar nicht anführen sondern
nochmal sie haben angefangen mit einer
falschen behauptung ihren ganzen vortrag
den sie eben gehalten haben über die
frage gegen wen eigentlich ermittelt
wird und das ist jetzt ja mal klar
gestellt sie haben ziemlich nicht
wiederholt weil es falsch nach und
deshalb habe ich noch mal darauf
hingewiesen dass wir eine sehr klare
strategie haben was alles zu tun ist das
habe ich auch gemacht und genau das
erwartet man von einem verantwortlichen
politiker dass er sich nicht wegduckt
sondern die dinge auf den weg bringen
die notwendig sind und wenn man eine so
kleine behörde übernimmt und sie groß
macht dann ist das richtig und wenn man
so große gesetzesänderung gegen
unglaublich viele lobbyisten durchsetzt
dann ist das auch richtig und wenn man
dafür sorgt dass comics und all diese
maßnahmen die gemacht haben worden sind
lange bevor ich bürgermeister oder
finanzminister war hart verfolgt werden
können dass nichts verkehrt dass wir
hinter allen hergehen und das ganze geld
wieder hören wollen dann ist das genau
das was man in dieser situation machen
muss und deshalb sage ich das ist der
richtige umgang mit dieser
herausforderung und das wird auch nicht
dadurch richtiger kritisiert dass man
mit falschen behauptungen gerüchten
durch die gegend wird also
gerne aus zwei punkte ergänzen zum einen
eine frage eine ganz offene und ehrliche
frage legen sie dann den bericht das
protokoll des finanzausschusses des
bundestags wird das jetzt offengelegt
noch vor der wahl und der andere punkt
der mir wichtig ist weil wir nach vorne
orientiert hier ja in die bundestagswahl
gehen das können wir in zukunft besser
machen wenn uns 50 milliarden jährlich
als staat verloren gehen durch
geldwäsche man muss sich das mal
überlegen das organisierte kriminalität
dass es drogenhandel das ist mafia wird
es von ihrer bundesregierung bzw das ist
das was ich möchte wenn wir eine
bundesregierung anführen als grüne nicht
mehr möglich sein dass wir mit bargeld
im großen großem maßstab immobilien
häuser kaufen kann weil da wird das
ganze geld in deutschland gewaschen und
wir sind eins der länder gerade im
europäischen vergleich was mit blick auf
geldwäsche wirklich schlecht dasteht und
das will ich ändern ich will dass wir in
zukunft verbieten dass das bargeld käufe
in großem maßstab ist um gegen diese weg
geldwäsche um gegen diesen steuerbetrug
wurzeln hoffen sie uns zu einem anderen
thema kommen laschet in südthüringen ist
der frühere verfassungsschutzchef maßen
kandidat für die cdu es ist heftig
kritisiert worden er sagt er will die
fehler der regierung merkel korrigieren
er verbreitet auch fake news über
twitter wolfgang schäuble hat nun gesagt
dass dieser mann die bandbreite der cdu
abbildet hat herr maßen für sie einen
platz in der cdu steht er in der mitte
der partei er ist mitglied der cdu und
steht er in der mitte der partei und
gehört der partei steht da nicht sondern
ja er ist ein mitglied der cdu und sie
wissen dass wir ein wahlrecht haben wo
jeder einzelne wahlkreis und
demokratischen verfahren seine
kandidaten aufstellt dieser wahlkreis
hat sich für ein nas unentschieden und
das respektieren wir fahren ein mitglied
ihres entschuldigung jetzt hat ein
mitglied ihres sohnes zukunftsteams
karin prien mehr oder weniger davon
abgeraten herrn maßen zu wählen und ihr
auf dem spd kandidaten im fraglichen
wahlkreis zu setzen würden sie herrn
maßen ihre stimme geben ich wäre ja im
wahlkreis aachen und vermaßen hat gesagt
fragt ihn fabry muss jetzt aus dem
zukunftsteam entfernt werden und meine
antwort ist karin prien bleibt da drin
die frage würden sie für die stimmen
werden worte auch keine würde fragen für
299 wahlkreise ich wähle im wahlkreis
aachen und es gibt viele unterschiede
das weiß aber jeder von mir und herrn
maßen und herr maßen wird sich an den
kurs halten müssen den ich vorgebe als
parteivorsitzender und wenn ich das
vertrauen habe auch als bundeskanzler
das heißt wenn er sich über
massenzuwanderung äußert und
staatsbankrott äußert und sagt ich bin
noch nicht mitglied der cdu geworden
damit 1,8 millionen araber einwandern
können dann ist das etwas was sie
kritisieren und auch inhaberin entgegnen
dass die entscheidung der
bundeskanzlerin
2015 richtig war dass sie die grenzen
nicht geschlossen hat dass wir für eine
geordnete migrationspolitik stehen aber
das alles was anderes hat die maus
geäußert wird nicht akzeptabel ist wir
sind bei annalena baerbock es gibt einen
ich will jetzt nicht sagen
vergleichbaren fall aber es gibt auch in
ihrer partei die diskussion um ein
parteimitglied klein ganz unbekanntes
boris palmer nämlich gehört boris palmer
zu den grünen oder wenn nicht warum
nicht er ist mitglied unserer partei
arbeit eine äußerung getätigt die
rassistisch war und deswegen habe ich
als parteivorsitzende und das
unterscheidet uns dann offensichtlich
auch an dieser stelle gesagt das kann
ich nicht so stehen lassen und mit ihm
gesprochen telefonierte und gesagt das
muss klargestellt werden es braucht eine
entschuldigung und da das nicht
stattgefunden hat haben dann die baden
württembergischen grünen auf einem
parteitag gesagt da müssen wir
überprüfen mit blick auf die
mitgliedschaft ob boris palmer wenn er
nicht bereit ist sich dafür zu
entschuldigen das klarzustellen mitglied
unserer partei bleiben kann und das ist
was ich glaube gerade in diesen zeiten
wo wir die nsu morde hatten wo wir hanau
das liegt jetzt zwei jahre zurück dieser
furchtbare anschlag auf eine synagoge wo
zwei menschen dann vor der tür ermordet
worden sind wo wir
alle natürlich wo wir hatten wo menschen
ermordet worden sind
jugendliche junge menschen wenn man den
eltern spricht die müssen daran glauben
dass in deutschland alles dafür getan
wird dass rassismus keinen platz hat
dass menschen dass jugendliche in
zweiter dritter generation hier in
deutschland sicher sind und das erwarte
ich auch von einer volkspartei cdu dass
sie die brandmauer nach rechts voll und
ganz schließt ich weiß wir wissen das
glaube ich alle als parteivorsitzende
das ist nicht immer einfach in den
eigenen parteien aber ihre vorgänger
dann zum beispiel annegret kramp
karrenbauer hat sich heftig auch mit
einem landesverband angelegt weil sie
klar und deutlich gemacht hat auch mit
blick auf die af.de ban nicht die
gleichsetzung mit links und afd sondern
klar gesagt hat wir müssen alles nach
rechtsaußen schließen und jedenfalls das
ist für mich ich bin ja
parteivorsitzender meiner partei ich
trete ja für bündnis 90 die grünen an
das oberste gebot auch für die nächste
bundesregierung
deutlich zu machen der kampf gegen
rassismus hat absolute priorität in
unserem land noch maske aber eine
erinnerung das war meine allererste wort
mehr ihr heute abend dass die grenze
gegen rechts steht und dass die größte
bedrohung für die demokratie von rechts
ausgeht von menschen
das haben sie im deutschen bundestag
getan wir beheben da auch wenn sie genau
zugehört hätten ich habe das sehr
sorgsam formuliert ich habe gesagt die
linke lehne ich ab aus ein paar punkte
die ich es nicht wiederholen will weil
es die sendung verlängert aber die
rechte bekämpfe ich die gehören nicht in
parlamente die sind die die geistigen
brandstifter die am ende zu solchen
morden führen wie auf unseren partei von
meinen parteifreund walter lübcke und
deshalb werden wir mit denen nicht
einmal reden nicht kooperieren und eine
klare brandmauer haben und da hat mich
nun auch persönlich keinen nachrücken
dann kann die linkspartei nicht mit der
afg ich habe gleich gesetzt würde ich
sage ich teile nicht dass wir aus der
nato austreten dass wir gegen europa
sagt mit beiden reden sie kategorischen
ist frau baerbock aber im ergebnis rede
ich dein ich habe gesagt wie koalieren
nicht mit beiden wird nicht kuriert das
ist die ausnahme korrigieren sie ihre
aufgaben ausgaben aus dem bundestag das
ja gut dann hat die sendung ja schon mal
ein kleines korrigiert der woche aber
lassen und uns über das thema corona
einmal sprechen im augenblick stockt die
impfkampagne es wird immer wieder die
frage gestellt 2g 3g das ganze wird sich
aber alles nur verbessern wenn die
impfquote stark was wollen sie tun um
mehr menschen dazu zu bewegen sich
impfen zu lassen
der herzlich appell aber ich glaube das
gilt für uns alle drei hier weil wir
alle drei an der stelle genau das
gleiche erreiche wenn es mehr menschen
sich impfen lassen daher bitte lassen
sie sich impfen kinder jugendliche haben
in den letzten anderthalb jahren alles
dafür getan dass erwachsene dass ältere
menschen sicher sind und jetzt müssen
wir als erwachsene alles dafür tun dass
kinder die noch nicht geimpft werden
können weiter in die schule weiter an
die kitas ergehen können und was müssen
wir tun zum einen aber festhalten dass
nach anderthalb jahren pandemie jetzt
eine infektions woche kommt es zeigt
wieder mit ihrer regierung der großen
koalition sind wir immer nur auf sicht
gefahren und wir brauchen jetzt eine
klare ansage
auch das finde ich kann man jetzt nicht
abwarten wie nach der bundestagswahl
dann zu sagen wir müssen mal gucken ob 2
gilt sondern ich finde wir müssen jetzt
dafür sorgen dass die schulen dass die
kitas offen gehalten werden das bedeutet
auch für menschen die sich impfen lassen
wollen das ist ein freies land das sie
dann aber nicht die gleichen freiheiten
in intelligenz gebieten haben können wie
andere weil ansonsten werden wir in den
nächsten herbst reinrutschen wo die
krankenhäuser überfüllt sind und wie wir
drohen in den nächsten lockt einzugehen
center häusern klare halt jetzt vor der
bundestagswahl haben sie alle drei einen
weiteren lockdown ausgeschlossen wir
sind in einer situation die selbst
menschen die sich gut auskennen man sagt
expertin oder wissenschaftler zu ihnen
als vierte welle betrachten und
bezeichnen was würden sie sagen herr
laschet herr scholz entschuldigung ist
jetzt die beste art und weise ist das
beste mittel um die aus den 61 prozent
impfquote die wir jetzt haben
eine höhere zahl zu machen und mehr
menschen zu überzeugt wir müssen werben
dafür dass sich viele impfen lassen wir
müssen viele überzeugen und ich nutze
den wahlkampf jetzt wo ich auf vielen
marktplätzen sprecher um ganz viele
anzusprechen überzeugt eure freunde eure
liebsten eure verwandten den sportverein
den stammtisch die kolleginnen und
kollegen im betrieb sagt ihnen das ist
doch gut was wir gemacht haben es
schützt euch und es schützt auch andere
und wir werden dass er die nächsten tage
noch mehr sehen die der anstieg der
infektionszahlen wird im wesentlichen
anstieg seien der etwas damit zu tun hat
dass die ungeimpften erwachsenen
gefährdet werden dass viele davon krank
werden sich anstecken dass einige auf
die intensivstation kommen und leider
auch einige sterben werden und deshalb
müssen wir alle davon überzeugen dass
sie sich jetzt impfen lassen und dann
möglichst vielen orten in deutschland
überall dafür sorgen dass man eine
möglichkeit hat sich ganz
nackt oder einer effizienten zu lassen
zum beispiel ist das den namen durch
gemacht worden in der elbphilharmonie
oder sportstätten das ist doch gut also
dass der impfstoff zum menschen kommt
und nicht der mensch zum impfstoff armin
laschet was würden sie sagen haben wir
bisher nicht gemacht um die menschen zu
motivieren sich impfen zu lassen es ist
die rettung
das ist war deshalb starten welches in
der nächsten woche eine große
werbeaktion um jetzt noch einmal die
letzten kräfte zu bündeln in nordrhein
westfalen sind wir in der oberen drittel
im oberen drittel beim impfen weil wir
auch sehr früh darauf geachtet haben
mobil unterwegs zu sein das haben wir
schon gemacht als der impfstoff noch
knapp war auch innviertel zu gehen wo
die menschen nicht so den zugang zur
information und b zum arzt haben dazu
impfen und das ist auch jetzt der fall
ein ganz ungewöhnliche orte olaf scholz
hat aus hamburg ein beispiel genannt ich
glaube das müssen wir jetzt tun wenn die
menschen nicht zum arzt gehen oder
vielleicht gar kein hausarzt haben
gerade junge menschen haben oft kein
hausarzt angebote machen da wo sie sind
in den universitäten in den klubs in den
innenstädten und so genau das ziel zu
schaffen so hoch zu kommen ohne eine
pflicht da sagen sie da dieses berühmte
wort von der impfpflicht würden sie ist
denn auch für bestimmte berufszweige
ausschließen muss nicht einen lehrer
muss nicht ein pfleger muss nicht mehr
ärzte schafften müssen nicht
krankenschwestern logischerweise geimpft
sein um eben anderen bürgern
gegenübertreten zu können die sie
betreuen
ich würde mir wünschen und das ist jetzt
in der letzten woche durch die
bundesregierung beschlossen worden dass
bestimmte berufsgruppen dem arbeitgeber
offen legen müssen ob sie geimpft sind
oder nicht ganz vertraulich aber man
muss in einem krankenhaus in einem
pflegeheim und wissen sind die
mitarbeiter geimpft und die
mitarbeiterin oder nicht ich hätte mir
ein anderes als in das wird es noch
weitere berufe aus denen das war nicht
möglich aber um gesundheitsschutz im
betrieb zu erhalten muss jeder des
offenen wo ist die nächste frage auch
annalena baerbock wie würden sie
entscheiden muss ist eine impfpflicht
geben für bestimmte
berufe für bestimmte berufszweige die so
sehr nah am menschen sind dass sie eben
einfach selbst geschützt sein müssen um
andere nicht zu infizieren aus meiner
sicht kann es auch hier keinen roman
geben weil das hat mir jetzt letzten
anderthalb jahre das immer so abgewartet
worden ist wenn wir jetzt erleben dass
wir gerade mit blick auf
pflegeeinrichtung und krankenhäuser zu
der situation kommen dass nicht genug
beschäftigte geimpft sind dann sollte
aus meiner sicht diese diese frage
durchaus angegangen wir haben das
gleiche gilt sie wären für eine
impfpflicht für
einzelne berufsgruppen wir haben das ja
zb bei der bundeswehr auch ist ja nicht
was was ganz komplett neu ist und wenn
wir jetzt die situation haben dass wir
zur auswahl haben schließen wieder kitas
und schulen gehen wir in den nächsten
lockdown dann muss aus meiner sicht
diese frage auch impfung für einzelne
berufsgruppen angegangen werden und das
ist vor allen dingen auch der
bildungsbereich den wir da ganz klar ins
auge fassen müssen zwei tagen ist mir
extrem wichtig weil das ist so ein
bisschen man schiebt einige
entscheidungen weg und dann redet man
immer über die intensivste entscheidung
das ist nach wie vor von der
bundesregierung verweigert wird dass es
testung am arbeitsplatz gibt wir
verlangen dass von unseren kindern in
den schulen zwei bis dreimal die woche
zu testen aber am arbeitsplatz soll das
nicht passieren das verstehe ich einfach
nicht warum die einfachen schritte die
wir jetzt eigentlich gehen können und
gehen müssen dass die nicht getan werden
und das will ich in eine entscheidung
die jungen 12 fragen also entschuldigung
sehr gleich richtig zu beantworten
impfpflicht für besondere branchen und
zweitens genau diese frage warum gibt es
darauf keine festlegung also erstens bin
ich gegen eine impfpflicht aber ich bin
dafür dass wir alle bezeugen und dabei
hilft das was wir jetzt gesetz gewünscht
auf den weg gebracht haben nämlich dass
in bestimmten berufsbereichen gefragt
werden kann ob man sich impfen lassen
das fanden nicht alle gut aber ich fand
das richtig ich habe mich sehr dafür
eingesetzt dass wir diese möglichkeit
jetzt schaffen und das wird dann auch
dazu führen dass wir einen besseren
überblick haben und das und damit
umgehen kann ich glaube wir werden
feststellen dass sehr viele dort wo es
drauf ankommt auch von ihrer möglichkeit
gebrauch gemacht haben sich impfen zu
lassen und das zweite ist natürlich
testen wer an den schulen wir testen
auch mit dem betrieben beide rechtlichen
grundlagen haben wir auf basis der
gesetze die jetzt unterwegs sind auf den
weg gebracht mit der entscheidung dass
wir die pandemische lage noch mal ein
paar monate verlängern haben wir die
grundlage für dieses testen in betrieben
und schulen gelegt jetzt
die masken pflichten abgeschafft worden
ist im grunde alle beschränkungen
aufgehoben worden ist das nicht auch
möglicherweise etwas was das impfen
befördern kann so eine aussicht auf wenn
wir die und jene quote erreicht haben
dann sind alle beschränkungen weg würden
sie sagen es gibt eine zahl bei der wir
die masken pflicht beispielsweise
aufheben können finde dass deutschland
einen sehr klugen moderaten weg geht wir
werben für das impfen das tun wir auch
überein stimmt hier das finde ich sehr
gut weil es ja länder gibt in denen das
in einer solchen runde keineswegs der
fall wäre das muss man ja auch mal
festhalten zweitens ist es so dass wir
dafür sorge tragen dass an orten wo das
sinn macht weiter masken getragen werden
zum beispiel in bahnen und bussen und
wir sorgen dafür dass getestet wird in
schulen und betrieben und wir denn
vorsicht an regeln an wenn man in ein
restaurant geht in eine
kultureinrichtung in dem dort nicht alle
rein können sie nur wer geimpft genesen
oder getestet ist und schaffen neue
möglichkeiten die auch vor ort ab und zu
leisten ist er verpflichtet seien
betriebe das ist ja ein wichtiges
argument denn da finden tatsächlich auch
ansteckungen statt warum wird das nicht
weiter verfolgt war die frage ich glaube
dass es völlig reicht dass die
testmöglichkeit in den betrieben
existiert und dass es nicht richtig wäre
wenn wir jetzt die pflicht der
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmer
konstruieren dass sie sich auch
entsprechend testen interessant dabei
erhalten das ist dann eins der probleme
wir rauschen in den nächsten herbst
herein das heißt sie haben nichts daraus
gelernt von den anderthalb jahren
pandemie man sagt kindern von den
kindern da verlangen wir dinge die man
von erwachsenen nicht verlangt meine
kinder alle kinder in diesem land die in
die schule gehen müssen sich zwei mal
die woche manchmal sogar dreimal die
woche testen und warum sagen sie bei
kindern verlangen wir dass und bei
wachsenden verlangt man das nicht ich
finde das eine absolute
ungleichbehandlung zwischen erwachsenen
und kinder wir müssten doch die jüngsten
wirklich schützen sie können ja nicht
sagen ja ich will die schulen offen
halten ja ich will keinen weiteren
lockdown aber die maßnahmen die wir
dafür brauchen die gehen wenn ich an das
einfach entscheidungen gibt wo man sagt
wir wollen die bürgern und bürger
überzeugen in diesem fall die
arbeitnehmenden arbeitnehmer mein
eindruck von den betrieben ist dass das
testen breitflächig genutzt wird viele
beschäftigte haben davon gebrauch
gemacht und es hätte natürlich an könnte
es hätte natürlich konsequenzen wenn man
sagt man muss sich testen lassen würde
das ja bedeuten dass jemand
möglicherweise seinen arbeitsplatz
verlieren könnte wenn er das nicht
mitmacht und deshalb haben wir uns
anders entschieden und gesagt wir wollen
es mit der test angebotspflicht für die
arbeitgeber organisieren und ich glaube
dass das in diesem stadium der pandemie
auch der richtige weg ist denn wir haben
ja schon sehr viele die geimpfte es
könnte konsequenzen haben für das
weitergehen dieser vierten welle wir
wollen an der stelle einmal ganz kurz
festhalten dass sie sich sehr fair
untereinander verteilt haben in bezug
auf die zeit ihres redens und ihre
äußerungen und würden dann genau an der
stelle weitermachen wir haben natürlich
genau bei krone und endlich das in der
fairness halber sagen darf die uhr von
herrn scholz läuft aber weiter
vielleicht angehalten werden ja im auge
zudem muss tatsächlich angehalten werden
aber wir achten darauf dass das alles
seine richtigkeit haben da
offensichtlich ein technisches problem
das stimmt es werden erklären und werden
sie sofort aufklären dazu das geht nicht
das ist die weiterläuft wir haben immer
noch weiter blick und kommen darauf
unbedingt zurück weil das geht auch
anders der korona zeit gemerkt dass
vieles in deutschland auch nicht so
richtig funktioniert nicht nur diese uhr
sondern vieles andere auch nicht was die
digitalisierung angeht faxgeräte in
gesundheitsämtern und ähnliches warum
ist es in deutschland immer noch nicht
so dass es flächendeckend wirklich
schnelles internet gibt warum herr
laschet gibt es immer noch nicht 5g an
jeder milchkanne ja als zu langsam
gegangen ist weil zu wenig investiert
worden ist wir haben viel aufgeholt aber
es reicht nicht aus aber es war ihre
partei die eine regierung hat waren
mehrere parteien in den letzten jahren
an der regierung meine auch wir haben
viel gemacht aber es reicht nicht
deshalb sage ich es kein weiter so geben
wir müssen auch da die kräfte bündeln
ich will ein digitalisierungs
ministerium errichten das dann wirklich
dieses thema mit all den ganzen ebenen
die im moment auf viele häuser verteilt
sind konzentriert an geht es ärgert mich
maßlos dass wir immer noch selbst auf
autobahnen kernnetz haben das ist kein
4000 weiß erlernt wie die bundesrepublik
deutschland die reden über 4000 weiße
flecke und über noch 4g und nun erinnern
wir uns ja auch das eigentlich über die
letzten vier legislaturen
digitalisierung immer angekündigt wurde
sie stand eigentlich in einen bei
programmen und nicht nur einmal in den
wahlprogrammen sie kommt nur irgendwie
nie in der realität an was ist ihr
befund annalena baerbock warum ist das
so wo sind die größten makel beim
organisieren dieser neuen infrastruktur
und wann können wir endlich darauf
hoffen dass wir nicht mehr mit dem
faxgerät und nicht mehr zum perso
verlängern in das bürgeramt müssen
sondern diese dinge auch in einer
digitalen verwaltung ankommen warum ist
das so weil man in der letzten
bundesregierung und sie haben ja 16
jahre als union regiert diese frage
digitalisierung sowie die frage
klimaschutz nicht zur absoluten chefin
sache gemacht hat digitalisierung ist
oder war muss man deutlich sagen die
aufgabe unserer zeit und sie haben dass
da so hin laufen lassen und zwischen den
ministerien einfache komplett verteilt
aber die frage was will ich anders
machen zukunftsthemen indes
bundeskanzlerin amt integrieren dass es
damit zentrale koordinierung gibt da
braucht man kein eigenes ministerium
führen sondern wir brauchen ja
digitalisierung in allen bereichen der
justiz zum beispiel da konkrete
vorschlag von meiner partei dass wir im
bund länder programm haben zur
digitalisierung der justiz wer erleben
da dass wir viele straftaten überhaupt
nicht vernünftig
bundesländerübergreifend erfassen können
weil alles noch wie sie gesagt haben
frau illner per fax hin und her geht
beim glasfaserausbau hat ihr
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier hat
sich versteigerungs runden gemacht dass
es immer immer teurer geworden
und da muss man jetzt die reißleine
ziehen so wie das zum beispiel spanien
gemacht hat und sagt das ist eine
hoheitliche staatliche aufgabe wir
müssen jetzt in den kommunen wohl nicht
ausgebaut wird staatlich dort mit rein
gehen auch von der bundesebene um gerade
in ländlichen regionen ich wohne ja
selber in einem bundesland wo wir viele
viele weiße flecken nach wie vor haben
in brandenburg das können wir uns nicht
leisten da sind dann nicht nur die
betriebe betroffen nicht nur die schulen
betroffen ärzte sagen ich kann doch hier
im ländlichen raum das was eigentlich
heute in der medizin möglich ist gerade
auch mit fern diagnostik gar nicht tätig
sein wenn ich keine vernünftigen
glasfaseranschluss ab und darf heißt das
dann wirklich zur chefin sache zu machen
und zu sagen der ausbau hat absolute
priorität und da geht der staat dann
auch eine könnte olaf scholz sagen wir
haben ja schon was getan wir haben zum
beispiel an den schulen einen digital
packt wir haben sechseinhalb milliarden
euro aufgelegt für die digitalisierung
von schulen allein das sagt gerade eine
steuer kfw studie das wird nicht
abgerufen und die studie sagt vor allen
dingen das liegt daran dass das
antragsverfahren so kompliziert und zu
wenig personal da ist daran kannst du
nun eigentlich wirklich nicht scheitern
daran kann es nicht scheitern soll es
auch nicht dass ein paar klare aussagen
ich glaube das liegt schon längst nicht
mehr am geld also für die breitband
infrastruktur für deutschland haben wir
zwölf milliarden euro bereitgestellt an
öffentlichem geld für die förderung von
künstlicher intelligenz 5 milliarden für
die frage wie geht es weiter mit einem
quantencomputer 2 milliarden für die
frage wie kriegen wir noch die nächsten
schritte hin nach 5 g mit 6 g und opera
nochmal zwei milliarden also viel geld
und auch das geld was sie eben
angesprochen habe für den digital packt
der ist zu spät gekommen es war gut dass
wir uns in dieser legislaturperiode
vorgenommen haben das grundgesetz zu
ändern
was wir mussten damit wir das machen
können das ist verhandelt worden hat
parteiübergreifende am ende auch
hingehauen und seitdem steht das geld
zur verfügung wenn wir früher los gelegt
hätten werden wir auch weiter gekommen
und aus meiner sicht ist das eine sache
die nicht aufhören darf denn wir müssen
sicherstellen dass mit der finanziellen
hilfe des bundes die länder und
gemeinden dafür sorgen dass alle schulen
an das netz angebunden sind und was mir
auch wichtig ist bei dieser frage ist
dass wir ein bisschen lernen aus der
rückschau denn was schiefgegangen ist zb
im bereich des mobilfunks war dass die
auflagen für die mobilfunknetzbetreiber
in der vergangenheit nicht hart genug
waren das haben wir diesmal anders
gemacht und darauf verzichtet dass wir
sehr sehr hohe erlöse erzielen können
die das sonst der fall gewesen wäre und
bei früheren situationen auch der dann
eingetreten ist in dem wir gesagt haben
das wichtigste ist die verpflichtung der
netzbetreiber zu einem flächendeckenden
angebot in deutschland wir haben das
dann noch ergänzt mit zusätzlichen
fördermitteln die wir aus den einnahmen
generieren die wir dann erlöst haben und
das finde ich auch den richtigen weg und
bei der gigabit gesellschaft diese für
die infrastruktur in deutschland
brauchen da müssen wir auch dafür sorgen
dass es nicht nur dabei bleibt dass wir
fördermittel bereitstellen sondern wir
müssen auch sagen der eine infrastruktur
verantwortung hat muss auch dafür sorgen
dass das flächendeckend geschieht aber
wir haben ja ein administratives problem
weil wie sie eingangs sagten ja eben
offensichtlich das geld da ist aber dann
tatsächlich der techniker fehlt um die
schule anzubinden und die
systemadministratoren nicht da sind um
dafür zu sorgen dass auch arztpraxen
angeschlossen werden wir sind immer noch
bei der frage lehren aus corona
anderthalb jahren wir haben sie sagen
moderat durch diese zeit gefunden andere
sagen es waren eine menge nicht da es
war nicht rechtzeitig die masken da
nicht rechtzeitig der impfstoff da und
es gab eben tatsächlich auch das problem
die gesundheitsämter richtig anzubinden
ihre zentrale lehre aus diesen
anderthalb jahren die wir jetzt erlebt
haben wäre jeweils was muss dringend
anders gemacht werden und zwar ein etwas
herr laschet war sie verändern was ist
ihre zentrale lehre aus diesen
anderthalb jahren kommen
vielen dank für die frage weil das ist
die hauptaufgabe für die nächste
bundesregierung liegen konsequenzen aus
dieser krise ziehen das eine ist
europäische autarkie und souveränität
dass wir wegen einem stück maske für
wenige cent irgendwo in der welt
produziert wochen lang einen
gesundheitsschutz hatte und die horrende
summen auf den weltmärkten bezahlt darf
nie wieder passieren wir müssen bei
medizinischen geräten bei masken
schutzkitteln auch sonstige geräte zu
übertreffen und nord sein und war selbst
diese produkte vorstellen
ihre wichtigste lehre
mit der politik schluss zu machen die
immer nur auf sicht fährt und nicht auf
vorsorge setzt und das heißt in so einer
partie in den ersten paar wochen wusste
niemand was diese pandemie bedeutet was
müssen wir eigentlich tun und dann war
aber vollkommen klar wir müssen
länderübergreifend zusammenarbeiten bund
und ländern europaweit zusammen arbeiten
und dann hätte es einen krisenstab
gebraucht und zwar im kanzlerin amt der
klar koordiniert was machen wir
eigentlich bei der beschaffung ganz am
anfang medizinisches personal
was machen wir bei den crooner helfen
dass sich der finanzminister gegen
wirtschaftsminister agiert und dann
kommen die korona hilfe nicht an was
machen wir mit blick auf die europäische
zusammen und lichtscheu wäre lautete
schon ein krisenstab damit es eine
politische verantwortung für gibt es
gebe ganz viel zu sagen aber ich will
weil das unmittelbar mit kroner
zusammenhängt sagen wir müssen den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst in
deutschland auf den modernsten stand
bringen da dürfen wir nicht mit aufhören
wenn die krise vorbei ist sondern das
ist eine aufgabe die die nächsten jahre
mit großem tempo voran gebracht werden
muss weil wir nicht wissen wann die
nächste große herausforderung auf
unseren gesundheitsdienst zukommt und
dann muss ja erstklassig digital
aufgestellt sein und ganz modern und mit
genug mitarbeiter und mitarbeiter vielen
dank jetzt wurde uns gesagt dass die
zeiten wieder stimmen wir werfen noch
mal einen kurzen blick darauf ganz
furchtbar weit sind alle nicht
auseinander frau berg hat einen kleinen
vorsprung die zeit von olaf scholz die
eben weiter lief ist auch korrigiert
worden und wir kommen herr laschet hat
eben gesagt das ist die wichtigste
aufgabe der neuen bundesregierung
möglicherweise ist aber auch dass die
größte aufgabe der neuen bundesregierung
nämlich die klimakrise zu bewältigen
frau berg die klima wende wird
mindestens so teuer wie die deutsche
einheit da sind sich eigentlich alle
einig warum schaffen wir den soli für
die deutsche einheit ab und machen nicht
einfach stattdessen ein klima soli so
dass jeder dafür zahlt einmal den sprung
hier vor der deutschen wende zum
klimaschutz machen also den soli
abzuschaffen das würde ja herr laschet
ich will den soli nicht abschaffen aber
ich will ihnen vorliegen dafür nutzen um
kinder aus der armut zu holen bei
derzeit bezahlen ihn vor allem die
reichsten in unserem land mit blick auf
ihre frage zum klimaschutz ja das wird
ein riesen große kraftanstrengung für
unsere gesellschaft aber es auch die
größte chance und deswegen müssen wir
jetzt das ist mein vorschlag mit blick
auf das geld 50 milliarden jährlich in
unsere infrastruktur
digitalisierung aber vor allen dingen
klima infrastruktur investieren das
heißt netze das heißt bahnausbau das
bedeutet windkraftanlagen zwei prozent
der landesfläche wirklich aufzustellen
auf jedes neue dach eine solaranlage
bringen weil wenn wir das nicht tun dann
wird es richtig richtig teuer dann wird
es unbezahlbar und deswegen darf beim
klimaschutz jetzt keine halben sommer so
lila oder nein und wir wandeln zu hören
laschet und sagen weil jetzt ein solcher
tag ist endet man doch nicht die politik
das haben sie herr laschet in der
flutkatastrophe gesagt wie viele solcher
tage muss man haben damit sie ihre
politik ändern fakt ist seit 1900 den
90er jahren wissen wir von weltklima
ereignissen wir wissen seit monaten von
frey des verf user die auf der straße
sind dass etwas passieren muss wir sehen
unwetterkatastrophen überall in der welt
wir sehen brände und merken wie das
klima sich verändert und deshalb ist
nicht erst in dem moment wo wir selbst
auch mal erwischt sind der zeitpunkt für
eine politik änderung da die die findet
statt sie findet übrigens in der
falschen priorität statt wenn das thema
so wichtig ist wie ich es halte er war
die reihenfolge in deutschland falsch
zuerst aus der kernenergie auszusteigen
und dann aus der kohle das ist jetzt
geschichte aber der weg war falsch denn
wir sind jetzt diese regierung hat den
kohleausstieg jetzt beschlossen im
gegensatz zu dem was vorher alles war
wir sind beim umbau unserer
energiewirtschaft und beim umbau unserer
industriegesellschaft und das ist die
eigentliche große leistung nicht mit
verboten und diesem und jenem sondern
tempo machen bei planung und genehmigung
die trassen schneller bauen und den
regenerativen strom vom norden in den
süden und industrie in den in die
industrieregionen zu bringen und
gleichzeitig unsere wirtschaft die
stahlindustrie die zementindustrie die
chemie zu gestalten damit sie
klimaneutral wirtschaft
das ist keine frage von sprüchen der
sondern wie man transformation in
unserem land leider sagen manche auch
revolution zu weil ist eine unglaubliche
dimension ist die der deutschen einheit
eben in allein ihren geldbeträgen nahe
kommt mit geschätzten einer billion um
in diesem bild noch mal zu bleiben herr
laschet also wenn da jetzt eine neue
kraftanstrengung wie die deutsche
einheit vor uns stünde dann wären
diesmal schon vorher die kassen leer es
würde alle deutschen betreffen und eine
figur wie helmut kohl wäre nicht da
ist das zu schaffen
ich glaube dass es viel bereitschaft
gibt ich bin ja mit der wirtschaft in
unserem land in intensiven gesprächen
die von sich aus angeboten haben wir
wollen den weg zur klimaneutralität
gehen die deutsche autoindustrie ist
längst auf diesem weg sich umzustellen
und ich finde wir müssen die jetzt auch
mal machen lassen die vorschriften die
die beiden wettbewerber alle vorhaben
werden das ziel nicht erreichen wir
haben so viel kreativität bei unseren
forschern wenn wir den durchbruch bei
der speichertechnologie zum beispiel
schaffen haben wir sehr viele fragen
gelöst
mit gesetzen mit verboten mehr
vorschriften sondern in dem eine dynamik
entsteht wo auch jeder lust hat dass da
etwas neues entsteht und das ist eine
bessere welt wird wenn wir zu wissen sie
mit der gleichen dynamik den menschen in
diesem land vielleicht sagen dass es
teuer werden wird und das ist um all die
dinge des lebens des unmittelbaren
lebens egal ob wohnen verkehr oder auch
arbeit eine verteuerung geben wird die
man beschlossen hat eben wenn wir zu
viel co2 ausstoßen das haben sie auch in
der großen koalition noch beschlossen
sie haben auch beschlossen dass es sogar
noch schneller gehen soll weil karlsruhe
sie dazu verpflichtet hat wann fangen
sie an den menschen zu sagen dass sich
ihr leben verteuern wird wenn sie zu
viel co2 ausstoßen naja wir sagen vor
allem den menschen dass ihr leben besser
wird wenn sie klimaneutral leben und
wenn sie beispielsweise ein kfw programm
das wir was ich vorhabe einzuführen
nutzen dass die dachfläche zu einem
zinslosen darlehen mit photovoltaik
genutzt werden kann dann ist
lebensqualität mehr da aber es ist nicht
unbedingt so dass alles teurer das alles
trüber das alles
menge teurer so herangehen wird es nicht
gelingen wenn wir dann neue
arbeitsplätze schaffen neue modelle
entwickeln dann auch weltmarktführer
sind und die wieder exportieren können
geht es besser als mit dieser rhetorik
es wird alles schlecht ist wird alles
recht aber es wird eine menge teurer
werden also zum beispiel sprit wird
teuerer daran aber die einnahmen die wir
aus der co2 steuer einnehmen wollen wir
nutzen um die bürokratische eeg-umlage
abzuschaffen das ist ein steuerungs
metern hat sich an der zapfsäule aber
möglicherweise wird sich das nicht so
schnell das spiegeln die der co2 preis
auch herr scholz wird weiter steigen wo
ist ein benzinpreis ein spritpreis wo
sie sagen da geht es nicht weiter
ich bin davon überzeugt dass es richtig
ist bei der co2 preise moderat
vorzugehen so wie wir uns das
vorgenommen haben mit den gesetzen die
wir auf den weg gebracht haben da habe
ich eben mich immer gegen all diejenigen
gewährten gesagt haben das muss jetzt
schnell alles viel teurer werden weil
das kauft sich wegen eines steigenden
spritpreise es nicht am nächsten tag
jemand ein neues auto auch nicht weil
das passiert wegen der welt marktlage
aber
auch nicht denn das aus steuerlichen
gründen passiert und deshalb ist richtig
dass wir sagen wir wollen einen
moderaten weg gehen und es ist auch
richtig dass wir sagen wir wollen in
dieser frage das geld den bürgern und
bürgern zurückgeben indem wir dafür
sorgen dass der strom billiger wird und
die kostenbelastung die auf der einen
moment herrscht
roben ist teuer und wird immer teurer
das benzin teurer es gibt menschen die
können ihr wohnen nicht mehr bezahlen
und es wird in diesem land
verteilungskämpfe geben ich finde denn
ich ihm widersprechen darf das sind die
themen die man diskutieren muss und
deshalb sage ich moderater weg ist der
richtige weg aber das größte thema das
wir bewältigen muss ist ein großer
müssen ist ein großer industrieller
umbau und ich bin dagegen dass wir so
tun als ob das alles eine sache ist die
nur bei uns als einzelnen bürgern und
bürgern hängt wenn wir uns vornehmen in
25 jahren und das hat dort schon per
gesetz beschlossen klimaneutral zu
wirtschaften dann ist das der größte
industrielle umbau den deutschland seit
weit über 100 jahren vor sich hat wir
haben 250 jahre wirtschafts und
industriegeschichte hinter uns die auf
kohle gas und öl beruhen und wenn wir
das jetzt ändern dann bedeutet das dass
wir sehr viel auf den weg bringen müssen
damit das auch tatsächlich funktioniert
wenn sie das projekt dann wollen sie
damit den leuten doch weiß machen das
macht die industrie damit habt ihr
nichts zu tun sie müssen doch irgendwann
anfangen den menschen zu sagen das wird
richtig finde erst mal müssen wir damit
anfangen dass wir das industrieprojekt
auch richtig beschreiben denn die
deutsche wirtschaft will das ja was ich
hier gesagt habe die chemieindustrie
weiß was sie will die
stahlindustrie weiß was sie will die
zementindustrie beste ist was sie will
der automobilbau weiß was er will der
maschinenbau alle sagen das geht aber
wir müssen dann statt kohle gas und öl
in ganz kurzer zeit strom einsetzen der
aus erneuerbaren quellen kommt also geht
es darum dass wir die
erzeugungskapazitäten in deutschland so
hoch machen jetzt sind die chemische
industrie zb sagt sie braucht 2050 so
viel strom wie deutschland insgesamt und
wenn wir vor dieser aufgabe uns drücken
dann haben wir ein problem deshalb meine
klare aussage zu diesem thema wir müssen
gleich am anfang der legislaturperiode
im ersten jahr weil wir ja nur diese
knapp 25 jahre haben dafür sorgen dass
genügend strom in deutschland erzeugt
wird damit all diese veränderung bei der
chemie bei der stahlindustrie bei all
den anderen wirtschaftszweigen unseres
landes stattfinden können dann wird uns
das auch gelingen dann wird unser leben
besser werden und das klima geschützt
werden können aber wenn wir das nicht
tun wenn wir nicht bereit sind auch
gesetze so zu ändern dass wir schnell
fertig sind dann wird das nicht klappen
weil es kann nicht sein dass eine
windkraftanlage zu genehmen sechs jahre
dauert das muss auch in sechs monaten
gehen und das sind die dinge um die es
jetzt geht es geht wirklich um industrie
und wirtschaftspolitik
und ich möchte nicht dass wir die sache
so klein reden und sagen das hätte nur
etwas damit zu tun was jeder einzelne
von uns macht darauf kommt es auch an
anderen aber auch abba und wollen sie
haben gerade gesagt es kann nicht sein
dass das so lange dauert wollen sie dann
auch darauf setzen dass anwohner eben
dagegen nicht mehr klagen dürfen das
vielleicht fledermäuse nicht mehr
gerettet werden sondern brachial einfach
schneller werden es geht um zwei prozent
der landfläche und es geht um offshore
windenergie also windenergie auf hoher
see und es geht um solarenergie was wir
ausbauen müssen und natürlich wird man
klagen können aber es wird nicht diese
zeitverzögerung geben können die wir
heute haben wir müssen also das
bauplanungsrecht ändern wir müssen auch
dafür sorgen dass wir die regelung zum
umwelt- und artenschutz so ändern dass
das schnelle genehmigung geben kann es
geht also um geschwindigkeit dazu haben
wir sehr konkrete vorschläge schon sehr
lange gemacht und die wollen wir gerne
umsetzen und ich sage noch mal
wenn wir bei dem tempo bleiben das wir
heute haben dann werden wir kein
einziges dieser ziele erreichen und dann
wird das mit der klimaneutralität nicht
klappen
voller liebe ich meine das ist jetzt
schön dass sie vieles von dem übernehmen
was die union sagt wenn ich mir diese
letzten vier jahren der großen koalition
anschaue war bei jenem bei jedem
beschleunigungs vorschlag bei jedem
entfernungs vorschlag die spd in der
koalition und die grünen in der
opposition
die beiden parteien die das alles
blockiert hat das stück tausenden
argumente verlassen das stimmt so
gesehen vor zwei jahren westfalen
berichten wo wir in festungs pakete
gemacht haben cdu und fdp damit exakt
die verfahren schneller wären instanzen
wegkommen wirklich mal entschieden wird
weil sich ein
laster in italien verlassen oder sie
reden mit wem eine flasche sie reden
thron räumen sie können sich kommt man
durch meine anton börner danach dürfen
sie entgegnen raten sie mal welche
beiden parteien sturm laufen gegen jede
einzelne vorschrift die wir wegnehmen
wenn das jetzt alles anders ist und wenn
sie nicht so für sich sprechen sondern
auch für die vielen abgeordneter partei
die das gegenteil verkündet dann ist das
ein gutes signal
ich glaub es nur nicht weil ich vier
jahre bei ihnen anders erlebt hat man
muss ja an dieser stelle sagen dass sie
ein bisschen sich davor drücken die
wahrheit zuzugeben die wahrheit ist dass
sie vor zwei jahren als cdu csu gesagt
haben man braucht nicht mehr strom wie
weit ist dass sie vor einem jahr gesagt
haben man braucht nicht mehr strom die
wahrheit ist dass sie noch im juni
gesagt haben man braucht nicht mehr
strom und das heißt man muss
zusammenfassen aus dieser linie folgt
eine weitere von der cdu csu geführte
bundesregierung würde deutschland
wohlstand und arbeitsplätze kosten weil
es nicht gelingen könnte stahlindustrie
chemie industrie maschinenbau zement
wirtschaft so zu modernisieren wie das
notwendig ist weil sie sich dagegen
gewehrt haben bis zuletzt und das ist
glaube ich der vorwurf dem sie
akzeptieren müssen und deshalb bin ich
dafür dass wir die ausbauziele hoch
setzen und dass wir alle gesetze so
ändern dass wir in ganz kurzer zeit
fertig werden dazu haben wir sehr
konkrete vorschläge auf den tisch
die übrigens auch immer
gerne trinkt gebildet werden wenn das
heute bei ihnen alles anders ist das in
ordnung in vier jahren war das nicht
möglich ich habe auch die
koalitionsverhandlungen damals
mitgemacht beim energiethema ihre partei
war immer die nicht mehr wollte aber
wenn alle jetzt werden planen muss
schneller werden gut aber ein es ist
nicht wahr es war keine parteipolitische
frage wie viel strom gebraucht wird
sondern es gab eine analyse des
bundeswirtschaftsministeriums
mit zwei instituten renommierten
instituten dem öko institut in freiburg
und trockners die eine bestimmte menge
benannt haben und dann hat man die neuen
ausbauphase betrachtet und jetzt hat der
wirtschaftsminister
die neuen zahlen vorgelegt insofern wenn
sie der wissenschaft vertrauen müssen
sie auch gutachten die wissenschaftler
machen akzeptieren die politik hat die
schlüsse daraus zu ziehen und dann hat
sie auch die konsequenzen haben nicht
auszumachen
laschet hat gas gegeben dass er zustimmt
dass er vor zwei jahren vor einem jahr
noch vor sechs vor drei monaten gesagt
hat man braucht nicht mehr strom und
dass er sich geirrt hat als bonus das
finde ich gesagt dass winter ist er
entscheiden mit ihrem tritt der
bundesrat nicht mehr diese der
bundesregierung aber sie sind derjenige
der zusammen mit all ihren
parteifreunden die wichtigste
modernisierungs aufgabe deutschlands
verpasst hat im licht weil sie nicht
wollten dass wir den stahlunternehmen
den chemie in unternehmen der
zementindustrie den strom geben den sie
für eine wirtschaft brauchen die ohne
kohle gas und es
aufgabe des bundesfinanzministers
unwürdig zu sagen sie haben mit der
stahlindustrie nicht gemacht ich habe
wahrscheinlich in den letzten jahren
mehr mit der stahlindustrie mit
thyssenkrupp und anderen gesprochen wie
wir das hinkriegen als sie die sgm aber
wenn sie sich einfach herzustellen und
zu sagen ihr könnt auch fair miteinander
umgehen aber sie können noch nicht sagen
wenn ich als ministerpräsident alles tue
eine transformation der
industriegesellschaft einzuleiten vor
wenigen wochen noch mit den großen
unternehmen dax konzerne des landes
zusammen gesessen hat die viele ideen
entwickelt haben die wir jetzt
aufgreifen müssen und die meistens auch
an den denken ihrer partei gescheitert
sind da kommen sie doch nicht hier so
raus ich meine lage sein sie haben das
alles vergessen oder können sich nicht
erinnern ich sag's ihnen jetzt damit sie
es wissen wir arbeiten an diesem thema
und scheitern an den bürokraten in ihrer
partei jetzt
einmal das wort geben das soll es auch
im wirklichen leben bereiten wenn ich
das kurz sagen darf dass ich an laschet
nicht zustimme und dass er diese fragen
klage
berbalk ist dran und hilft uns
vielleicht noch mal bei der beantwortung
von zwei sehr klaren und einfachen
fragen erstens müssen wir für das von
der großen koalition beschlossene
klimaschutzgesetz früher aus der kohle
aussteigen als
2038 und die zweite frage ist 75 euro
wollen sie den bürgern zurückgeben in
einem sogenannten bürgergeld das ist ne
tank quittung wird das reichen man hat
er drei facette vielleicht mal der erste
punkt angefangen sie haben jetzt hier
beide in ihrer vergangenheitsbewältigung
der cdu und der spd deutlich gemacht
warum wir beim klimaschutz da stehen wo
wir derzeit stehen und das bedeutet wir
verfehlen unsere klimaziele mit
dramatischen auswirkungen weil sie beide
deutlich gemacht haben sie haben sich
nicht an den lösungen orientiert sondern
sie haben sich immer nur die schuld in
die schuhe geschoben wer eigentlich was
verhindert und wenn wir jetzt über die
zukunft reden und das will ich es geht
jetzt darum die nächste wahl und diese
nächste bundesregierung die ist die die
noch aktiv einfluss auf die klimakrise
legen kann und das heißt dann wir müssen
früher aus der kohle aussteigen und zwar
deutlich vor
2038 wir können doch nicht das wollen
sie beide aber wenn sie jetzt ihre
meinung ändern weil sie sagen wir sind
jetzt die größten klima schütze dann
wäre es ja super dann hätten wir schon
mal ein erfolg wir können auch nicht 17
jahre lang weiter so machen als wäre
nichts passiert deswegen ist für mich
klar die nächste bundesregierung muss
den kohleausstieg vorziehen auf 2.030
wir müssen zweitens im automobilbereich
in der mobilität endlich überhaupt auf
die klimaziele kommen sie haben gefragt
was ist das mit dem gesetz der
bundesregierung nachdem das
bundesverfassungsgericht ja gesagt hat
liebe große koalition so geht das nicht
weiter ihr gefährdet die freiheit
unserer kinder haben sie gesagt okay wir
haben verstanden aber was war die
einzige maßnahme die sie gemacht haben
sie haben für in 25 jahren beschlossen
dann sollten wir beim klimaschutz weiter
seien aber für hier und heute keine
antwort gegeben und die zweite antwort
muss deswegen sein wir müssen raus aus
dem fossilen verbrennungsmotor und sie
kommen wir damit ihren schlagworten
immer von verboten jedes verbot ist auch
ein innovationstreiber das sehen wir
doch jetzt bei den deutschen
automobilherstellern wünschte unruhigen
wo ich wo ich nicht erst im wahlkampf so
wünschen ohne verbot vorbeigeschaut habe
sondern in den letzten acht jahren in
dem ich wirtschafts und klimapolitik
mache ist ganz klar gewesen die zukunft
im individualverkehr ist elektromotor
und deswegen braucht es vor 2030 muss
dafür gesorgt werden dass dann nur noch
emissionsfreie von 70 euro das ding der
dritte punkt ist die industrie und da
brauchen wir keine analyse herr scholz
die industrie sagt wir brauchen jetzt
die wasserstoff infrastruktur
deswegen will ich dass wir energie
partnerschaft mit anderen ländern
schaffen und die infrastruktur verlegen
und dafür brauchen wir das geld dass sie
nicht bereit stellen jetzt auf die frage
75 euro das sind alles die politischen
aufgaben und wir können ohne groß und
die sind groß und die brauchen wir mit
klaren gesetzlichen regelung weil wenn
sie die nicht wollen dann müssen wir das
alles über den co2 preis machen das
möchte ich nicht das wäre nämlich sozial
ungerecht sondern unser vorschlag ist
dass wir signalisieren
fossile energie wird teurer beim tanken
bei der heizung aber damit dass sozial
gerechtes geben wir jährlich 75 euro pro
person an die menschen zurück aber nur
als ein bestandteil die andere frage die
sie angesprochen haben ist wie
unterstützt menschen die das auto
wechseln indem wir die umstiegs prämie
bei elektroautos erhöhen von 6000 euro
auf 9000 euro für menschen die ein
geringes einkommen haben und der dritte
punkt und das blockieren sie auch
derzeit ist dass sie mit blick auf die
heizung sagen das könnte ich die
mieterin bezahlen
sowohl stichwort wir halten ganz kurz
fest dass sie sich schon wieder total
fair untereinander behandeln man möchte
es nicht glauben wenigstens auf die zeit
bezogen ist das so
einen kleinen vorsprung hat frau berbalk
und auch nur wegen dieses letzten
statements wir wandern jetzt tatsächlich
zum wohnen und zum heizen und möchten
als allererstes fragen frau baerbock
wohnungsnot in den städten ist ein
massives problem das weiß jeder und hat
es natürlich auch verfolgt jetzt jüngst
aber auch unendlich hier wenigstens in
berlin die grüne spitzenkandidatin will
für enteignung von
wohnungsbaugesellschaften stimmen würden
sie das auch ganz kurze antwort nein und
das wohl auch nicht die grüne
spitzenkandidatin sondern sie hat einen
fairen pakt vorgeschlagen
sie hat deutlich gemacht damit wir
enteignung verhindern weil wir das nicht
wollen müssen wir jetzt mit einer klaren
regelung zum mietpreis oder brände
grenze in den städten wie berlin wo
menschen aus ihren vierteln vertrieben
werden dafür sorgen dass es zu dieser
maßnahme nicht kommen wird und das ist
auch mein vorschlag dass auf bundesebene
den städten ermöglicht wird wo wirklich
die mieten explodieren dass man dort mit
preisobergrenzen einziehen kann ich
würde nur die antworten der beiden
kassen von den bayern als spannend
wollen sie aus der kohle früher
aussteigen ja oder nein laut schon beim
einhalten sie haben es gerade
angesprochen eine mietobergrenze mieten
deckel wie auch immer man das will ist
in berlin gerade sozusagen
verfassungsrechtlich gescheitert aber
man kann es bundesweit einführen wenn
man das möchte herr laschet herr scholz
was war die frage ob einmieten deckel
eine mietobergrenze ein weg ist die
mieten zu begrenzen und mieter zu
entlassen diese mieten deckel den rot
rot grün in berlin erdacht hat ist ja
gerade vor dem verfassungsgericht
gescheitert in berlin wird immer weniger
investiert und deshalb ist doch das
entscheidende
wir brauchen mehr wohnraum wir brauchen
mehr bauen wir brauchen mehr und
schnelleres bauen das muss doch das ziel
sein das hat aber nur sehr langfristig
die mieten sozusagen etwas entlasten
wenn sie jetzt kurzfristig mietern
helfen wollen dass die mieten nicht mehr
steigen was schlagen sie dabei wir haben
ja mehrere mechanismen mieten können ja
auch nicht ins uferlose steigen wir
haben ja heute schon regeln wie mieten
steigen können aber die frage ist doch
ob sie jemanden
den sie ermutigen wollen dass er baut
dass er endlich mehr wohnungen gebaut
damit ermutigen dass sie ihm
gleichzeitig so viel schranken auflegen
dass sie das geld woanders investiert
wir müssen doch dem der geld investieren
will sagen 'bitte nicht da und da und da
und da sondern ein anreiz tue es beim
wohnen mach es beim bauen hier ist das
bauland hier ist die entbürokratisierung
hier ist die einfachere bauordnung fun &
bauer so allerdings all das was da
erdacht wird macht es komplizierter und
ich sag es wird nichts helfen bei der
not in den großen städten die wir
derzeit haben brachte geller herr scholz
nacht des wissens schneller wer einen
mieten deckel eine stärkere mietpreis
bremse ich glaube dass wir zwei dinge
gleichzeitig anpacken müssen das eine
ist mehr wohnungen bauen wir haben es in
deutschland schon mal geschafft 800.000
wohnung in einem jahr zu bauen das war
1973 da werden wir es wohl jetzt
schaffen jedes jahr 400.000 wohnungen zu
bauen das sind 100.000 mehr als jetzt
und darunter müssen auch hunderttausend
geförderte sozialwohnung sein sonst
werden wir das nicht hinbekommen dass
wir in irgendeiner weise das wohnungsnot
problem in den städten den orten wo
viele hinziehen wollen lösen können so
und daneben brauchen wir aber weil das
ja eine gewisse zeit dauert auch alles
was dazu beiträgt dass die mieten jetzt
nicht durch die decke schießen und
deshalb bin ich dafür dass wir bei
neuvermietung den anstieg der mitte
begrenzen die gesetze haben wir die
müssen wird das besser machen uns
verlängern und das wäre aber auch dafür
sorgen dass die mieten nicht in den
nächsten jahren so sehr steigen können
wie sie ohne eine zusätzliche
als bundeskanzler würde es einen mieten
deckel geben den sie bundesweit
anstreben streben ein mit moratorium
einen das bedeutet dass die mit anstiege
begrenzt sind in etwa in richtung der
inflationsrate nicht so sehr steigen
können dieses gegenwärtig tun aber wir
wollen keinen beschluss machen der
lautet gar keine steigerung wäre total
keller schätzt sie haben proben geredet
und dem gedanken folgt man natürlich
irgendwie erstmal sofort pro tag werden
in deutschland
72 wohnungen aus der sozialbindung
genommen das sind im jahr hochgerechnet
um die 30.000 diesen prozess und vorgang
beklagen wir schon eine ganze weile wenn
sie wiederum mit der dynamik noch mal
beschreiben wie man eben bezahlbaren
wohnraum also bezahlbare sozialwohnungen
gebaut und möglichst schnell wären ihnen
die bürger sicher auch dann ja aber das
gehört dazu wir brauchen mehr wohnungen
aber wir brauchen auch mehr sozialen
wohnungsbau wir haben die programme und
der muss ausgedehnt werden weil exakt
das phänomen stimmt viele zeiten laufen
aus dafür brauchen wir neue bezahlbare
sozialwohnungen wir sind niemals haben
wir ja ich bin in meinem land und sie
müssen in ganz deutschland so gebaut
werden damit wir diese ausgewogenheit
und den sozialen zusammenhalt übrigens
auch in den vierteln hinkriegen und ein
zweites ist glaube ich auch noch wichtig
wir müssen das wohnen im ländlichen raum
attraktiv halten damit nicht jeder
glaubt für gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse muss ja in die stadt
ziehen das überhitzt ja noch einmal mehr
die wohnungsmärkte in den städten
deshalb will ich mich dafür einsetzen
dass wir auch im ländlichen raum
möglichkeiten haben doch zu leben da
geht vom schnellen internet bis hin zur
monster versorgung und die haben immer
gut acht thema wohnen ganzheitlich
denken um erfolgreich zu haben das thema
sozialen zusammenhalt angesprochen herr
scholz sie regieren seit 1998 mit einer
unterbrechung immer mitunter immer hieß
es weg mit der zweiklassengesellschaft
im gesundheitssystem wie ist es dazu
gekommen
sichern sie jetzt zu ein nächster
koalitionsvertrag wird eine
bürgerversicherung also eine
krankenversicherung in die alle
einzahlen
definitiv enthalten wir würden das gerne
voranbringen das hat auch in den letzten
wahl programm gestanden aber wir haben
uns nicht verständigen können das kann
man ja mal so sagen ich glaube dass ganz
besonders im bereich der pflege deutlich
wird wie sodass hin macht dort werden
die gleichen leistungen er brachte es
werden zwei kassen gesammelt wenn man
das besser zusammenführen würde dann
hätten alle mehr geld das wir billiger
und wir könnten dafür sorge tragen dass
die löhne und gehälter für die
pflegekräfte steigen wir können dafür
sorge tragen dass die angebote besser
werden wir könnten dafür sorgen dass
mehr arbeitskräfte in der pflege tätig
sind denn viele können sich ja
kaum noch vorstellen dass sie lange dort
bleiben der wechsel ist ungefähr sieben
bis neun jahre bleibt jemand da in den
beruf und dann wechselt er das ist nicht
gut und wenn wir das ändern wollen
müssen wir mehr solidarität schaffe und
dazu würde diese zusammenarbeit diese
kooperation aber machen sie das also
bedingungen also ich möchte nur
verstehen ob das eine
herzensangelegenheit ist oder
verhandlungsmasse das ist eine
herzensangelegenheit schon seit langer
zeit und deshalb möchte ich gerne also
starkes mandat dass sich das auch
durchsetzen diese bedingungen machen ich
finde alles was in meinem wahlprogramm
steht es eine bedingung und dann gucken
wir mal wie weit bekommen kurze frage an
alle sollen private krankenkassen
abgeschafft werden herr laschet nein
hier unterscheiden wir uns fundamental
fundamental und mich wundert auch dass
man angesichts der erfahrungen in europa
als finanzminister einen solchen
vorschlag machen kann die
einheitsversicherung die wir haben in
europa
dänemark in großbritannien haben ein
schlechteres gesundheitssystem zur folge
und die die es sich leisten können
finden wieder ihre umwege wie sie beste
gesundheit für sich selbst dann
organisieren und deshalb ist unser
gesundheitssystem gut es ist ein starkes
gesundheitssystem und dies in frage zu
stellen mit solchen einheits modellen
halte ich das ist das plädoyer von armin
laschet wir wollen unbedingt noch hören
wie das gesundheitswesen der zukunft von
annalena baerbock aussieht wir können ja
jetzt nicht mehr corona pandemie haben
wo menschen alles in den krankenhäusern
gegeben haben und dann sagen wir können
nicht mehr es reicht nicht wenn ihr uns
als pflegekräfte als erste klatscht
sondern es muss sich etwas ändern und
das hat für mich absolute priorität in
der neuen bundesregierung dafür zu
sorgen dass unsere gesetzliche
krankenversicherung unsere öffentlichen
krankenhäuser gestärkt werden das heißt
beim fallpauschalensystem klingt total
technisch aber das bedeutet dass wir
nicht alles nur auf profit was rechnet
sich auslegen sondern in vorsorge
element aus öffentlicher hand einziehen
damit die betten auch wirklich zur
verfügung stehen damit menschen sich
nicht kaputt arbeiten und ja ich will
dem weg zu einer bürgerversicherung
gehen die bedeutet dass viel mehr
menschen einzahlen die erste schritt ist
dafür zu sorgen dass menschen die jetzt
privat versichert sind in die
gesetzliche wechseln können das wollen
ja ganz viele menschen weil diese zwei
klassen system führt auch dazu dass zb
in ländlichen regionen wo fachärzte
mangelware sind wenn man anruft und sagt
ich bräuchte einen termin beim hautarzt
immer gefragt wird sind sie gesetzlich
oder privat versichert und wenn du
privat versichert ist kann sogar schnell
kommen und gesetzlich musste monatelang
warten und das halte ich für zutiefst
ungerecht das ist also ein thema wo sie
beide sich einigen können frau werbung
und herr scholz das sieht bei der rente
sehr ähnlich aus sie wollen beide ein
rentenniveau von 48 prozent
garantieren im augenblick ist das schon
und kostet sehr sehr viel geld wenn das
für die zukunft weiter garantiert werden
soll dann wird es noch viel mehr
steuergeld steuerzuschuss kosten das ist
doch aber eigentlich unbezahlbar es ist
nicht unbezahlbar das ist aus meiner
sicht eine mehr und deshalb will ich das
auch gern begründen wenn sie das mir
gestatten erstens wir haben in den 90er
jahren viele experten experten gehört
die haben uns erzählt das wird alles
nichts werden mit der rente das klappt
alles nicht mehr sie haben uns für diese
zeit vorher gesagt dass wir sehr hohe
beiträge zahlen werden sie haben uns
auch gesagt dass wir viel weniger
arbeitnehmer und arbeitnehmer haben
werden das gegenteil ist eingetreten
bezahlen heute geringere beiträge als
zurzeit von helmut kohl und wir sind
jetzt in einer situation wo wir etwa
sechs millionen arbeitnehmern und
arbeiten immer mehr haben die in die
rentenkasse einzahlen und deshalb ist
die antwort für die zukunft auch dass
wir sicherstellen müssen dass möglichst
viele eine gute beschäftigung haben wenn
wir vorankommen würden zum beispiel bei
der beschäftigung
möglich bei den
beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten und chancen
von frauen dann wäre das ein ganz ganz
großer fortschritt und würde für die
frauen gut sein und für die rente und
wenn jemand der mit 56 seinen job
verliert eine plausible annahme haben
kann dass er auch wieder einen guten
neuen job findet dann würde das auch
schon viel das heißt sie sagen dass
diese 48% wir erinnern uns an die
doppelte haltelinie von andrea nahles
dass die auch für einen berufseinsteiger
für einen studierenden heute ein
versprechen in die zukunft ist das ist
mir sogar sehr wichtig ist ja das macht
ja wenn über rente gesprochen wird immer
gedacht das geht nur um die renten und
ränder um die geht ja ob die 50 jährigen
sondern es geht auch um die jungen leute
wer jetzt mit 17 die schule verlässt der
junge mann die junge frau einen lauf
gehabt nach neuen zahlen fünf jahrzehnte
beiträge und die müssen natürlich wissen
ob sich das am ende auch austrägt und
deshalb eine ganz klare aussage wir
müssen ihm die garantie geben dass es
erstens keinen weiteren anstieg des
renteneintrittsalters gibt und zweitens
dass wir dafür sorge tragen dass das
rentenniveau auch stabil glatt war diese
zeit aber es 2025 haben wir das ja auch
jetzt schon in der finanzplanung geht
auch länger
das ist
nämlich genau die sie können sich gleich
zur olaf scholz äußern wir würden
trotzdem gerne wissen mit ihnen als
bundeskanzler
lebensarbeitszeit bis 67 48 prozent wird
gehalten fragezeichen also ja ich kann
das verbinden mit der antwort dass die
antwort nicht seriöses sie können nicht
einem der heute das berufsleben
einsteigt sagen es wird alles so bleiben
wie es ist dieses weiter so wird uns da
nicht helfen sondern wir werden über
neue formen nachdenken müssen dafür gibt
es renten kommissionen und wir werden am
liebsten aus meiner sicht
parteiübergreifend auch mit dem der dann
opposition ist ein neues rentensystem
entwerfen können aber wenn man sagt dass
bleibt gleich das bleibt gleich jedes
jahr tun wir neue milliarden aus dem
bundeszuschuss drauf dann geht das exakt
zu dieser zulasten dieser jungen
generation die sie gerade angesprochen
haben denn die werden das zahlen müssen
den heutigen rentnerinnen und hätten
dann können wir doch alle sagen eure
rente ist sicher und es war übrigens
norbert blüm der damals dieses system
verteidigt hat der gesetzlichen
rentenversicherung gegen all die die
außerhalb als experten rat gegeben haben
und gesagt haben dass brauchen wenn ich
es ist gut dass wir es haben aber es
muss weiter entwickelt werden und
deshalb
ist eine stellschraube unsere generation
rente wie wir bei jedem neu geborenen
ansetzen wollen wo wir einen fond
aufbauen wo auch dessen rente in der
zukunft einmal gesichert ist wir müssen
bei der betrieblichen altersversorgung
ein besseres system die riester-rente
die mal eingeführt wurde ist so nicht
effektiv und nicht attraktiv
wir brauchen ein paar stellt schon aber
nur ein weiter so wir müssen nichts
ändern verspricht den menschen keine
serie bekannten bessere idee als immer
mehr geld jetzt sind schon 26 prozent
des bundeshaushalts fließen in die
rentenkasse ist das nicht sind die
vorschläge von herrn lasseter nicht ein
bisschen zielführender na ja herr
laschet macht den ganzen abend sagte
immer analyse und was irgendwie in 20
jahren passieren wohl beim klima in 20
jahren und bei der rente sagen sie auch
dann jetzt zahlen sie ein für in 40
jahren wenn jugendliche in rente gehen
aber wir müssen doch jetzt dafür sorgen
dass wir das rentenniveau stabilisieren
dass wir die beitragssätze stabilisieren
und vor allen dingen rentnerinnen und
rentner die nach wie vor am ende des
monats jeden euro umdrehen müssen nicht
wissen kann ich mir das
geburtstagsgeschenk für meine enkelin
noch leichten da müssen wir doch für
eine echte garantie rente sorgen und
deswegen ist mein vorschlag durch vier
konkrete punkte zum teil überschneiden
die sich in dem wir jetzt dafür sorgen
dass das rückgrat dieses sozialstaats
eine gesetzliche rentenversicherung
gestärkt wird und das allererste ist und
das wollen sie nicht und deswegen haben
wir ein problem fachkräfte zuwanderung
wir sind ein einwanderungsland wenn wir
die menschen die hier leben allen
ermöglichen auch zu arbeiten dann zahlen
sie in die sozialversicherungssysteme
wirklich mit ein der zweite punkt ist
wir brauchen einen gesetzlichen
mindestlohn von 12 euro und bei das für
aber dann die renten am ende noch nicht
ausreicht eine anhebung des
arbeitgeberanteils bei der einzahlung in
die rente auf 15 euro auch das
stabilisiert die rentenkassen der dritte
punkt ist wir müssen endlich dafür
sorgen dass all die millionen frauen die
eigentlich in vollzeit arbeiten wollen
es aber nicht können weil wir nicht
genug kinderbetreuungsplätze haben
endlich in vollzeit arbeiten auch die
zahlen in die rente dann entsprechend 1
und der vierte punkt der klingt klein
aber der gehört zur solidarität dazu
selbstständige auch die sollten in die
gesetzliche rentenversicherung mit 1 1
können und zuallererst abgeordnete
minister leute wie wir damit für die
gesetzliche rente einmal auf die zahlen
das haben wir nicht nur versprochen
sondern das tun wir auch sie sind
erstens immer noch korrekt das ist schön
und zweitens liegen sie wirklich mit
minimalen unterschieden strecken weil
sie nur um sekunden auseinander es ist
ein gebot der fairness dass immer wieder
zu sagen dass sie diese dinge
untereinander wie gesagt die zeit
betreffend wenigstens gut
austarieren wir wollen und müssen uns
natürlich noch mal mit dem großen thema
steuern und finanzen befassen vielleicht
ist aber der hinweis ganz gut die frage
einzuschließen damit wir sie nicht
vergessen nämlich die nach der
zuwanderung wir haben eine zahl in der
großen koalition auf die hat man sich
verständigt von 150 bis 200 tausend
menschen die als asylsuchende nach
deutschland kommen und es gibt herr
laschet 400.000 das an notierte
bundesanstalt für arbeit die wir
bräuchten um unsere wirtschaft am laufen
zu halten
was sagt armin laschet wenn er
zukünftige bundeskanzler wäre zu diesen
beiden zahlen ungefähr auch 150000
asylsuchende bis 200.000 und ungefähr
400.000 menschen pro jahr die wir
brauchen am arbeitsmarkt
fakt ist dass wir heute ein modernes
einwanderungsgesetz haben insofern habe
ich gar nicht verstanden weshalb sie
gesagt haben wir seien dagegen wir haben
es und wir müssen um qualifizierte
zuwanderung in der welt werben dazu
brauchen wir ein neues klima das
signalisiert wir laden jeden ein der
einen beitrag leisten kann nach
deutschland zu kommen wir sind gegen
eine einwanderung in die sozialsysteme
sondern es geht darum qualifizierte
einwanderung nach deutschland
besser möglich zu machen als das heute
der frage noch mal nach der zweite teil
ihren zahlen das asylrecht kennt keine
obergrenze wir können zielgrößen
definieren das sind die 150 bis 200
tausend aber wenn jemand einen
rechtsanspruch hat und er politisch
verfolgt ist kann er auch dieses also
recht in anspruch nehmen und deshalb
wollen wir eine sage ordnete migration
keine illegale migration kein schlepper
tun sondern eine geordnete migration vor
allem migration in den arbeitsmarkt da
wo menschen gebraucht werden und ich bin
auch dafür dass potenzial derer zu
nutzen die im land sind die deutsche
sprache haben die zum teil in ausbildung
sind noch besser zu nutzen in nordrhein
westfalen haben wir sehr weite bleibe
möglichkeiten für die die gut integriert
sind weil in jedem steckt ein potenzial
und das müssen wir helfen sie uns zum
thema steuern und finanzen kommen herr
laschet kriegen wir von ihnen heute
abend das versprechen dass in einer
regierung laschet keine steuern erhöht
werden für niemanden
steuererhöhungen sind in dieser phase
unserer wirtschaft der falsche weg weil
wir haben mit viel geld die betriebe
durch die pandemie gebracht jetzt ist
die zarte hoffnung da dass wir zu neuem
wirtschaftswachstum kommen und wir haben
doch vor der pandemie gelernt wenn wir
keine steuern erhöhen nimmt der staat
mehr geld ein weil die wirtschaft
floriert weil viele menschen
beschäftigung haben und weil viele am
ende auch einzahlen und genau daran
müssen wir jetzt anknüpfen
das ist der fundamentale unterschied
zwischen mir und den beiden
mitbewerberinnen und mitbewerber
ich halte den weg über steuererhöhungen
über neue belastung über vermögenssteuer
erbschaftssteuer einkommenssteuer
linke mit noch ein paar vorschläge mehr
da sie fragen gleich nach entlasten
wollen er soll von der ja zunächst war
stolz ist doch mal ehrlich
warum das aus ihrer sicht nicht geht
ohne steuererhöhungen da zunächst mal
muss man dazu sagen dass in den
wahlvorschlägen die die union zum
beispiel macht ja die idee steht dass
leute die so viel verdienen wie ein
bundesminister oder noch mehr
steuersenkung bekommen sollen da haben
einige ausgerechnet dass das was dort
vorgeschlagen ist für solche
steuerzahler wie mich und leute die noch
mehr verdienen und für sehr gut
verdienende unternehmen zusammen 30
milliarden euro pro jahr kosten kann und
ich finde das ist unfinanzierbar wir
haben jetzt 400 milliarden euro schulden
gemacht am ende des nächsten jahres wird
es soweit sein um die krise zu bekämpfen
wir haben dafür sorge getragen dass
arbeitsplätze und unternehmen gerettet
werden wer mit der kurzarbeit über zwei
millionen arbeitsplätze gerettet viel
geld für unsere gesundheit ausgegeben
und all das wird nicht gehen wenn man
jetzt sagt die leute die sehr viel geld
verdienen die sollen erstmal eine
steuersenkung bekommen das wird nicht
funktionieren das heißt dass
gegebenenfalls auch die unternehmen und
die unternehmen die sie eigentlich jetzt
brauchen für diese große transformation
das land verlassen nein das werden sie
ja nicht das ist ja ein ganz ganz großes
gericht im übrigen haben wir ja im
übrigen wir sind ein sehr
leistungsfähiges wirtschaftsland das
muss man dazu sagen haben wir gerade
einen großen erfolg errungen wir haben
drei jahre lang verhandelt darüber dass
wir eine weltweite verständigung
zustande bekommen über globale
mindestbesteuerung von unternehmen das
ist jetzt erfolgt das wird in wenigen
tagen alles verändert werden und dann
werden wir sehen dass der dumping
wettbewerb zwischen den gestatten dass
die steuern immer geringer werden ein
ende finden wird mitgemacht haben länder
wie die usa und großbritannien europa
japan wir werden 134 staaten glauben sie
grüßen mit diesen worten von herrn
scholz
mit den digital konzern mit den das ohne
steuererhöhungen selbstverständlich
nicht gehen würde und dass es mit den
steuererhöhungen keine million
unternehmer aus dem land treibt
ich hatte steuern sind ja kein
selbstzweck wenn alles gut wäre da
müsste man sagen wir müssen nichts
verändern aber wir erleben eine
situation wo die ärmsten in unserem land
immer ärmer werden und die reichsten
immer reicher plus eine situation nach
corona dass wir in die krankenhäuser
investieren müssen dass wir in schulen
investieren müssen digitalisierung
investieren müssen und erst recht in
klimaschutz und dann stellt sich ja die
frage wenn man das wirklich machen will
und ich will das machen weil das ist die
substanz unseres landes dann müssen wir
das finanzieren und da gibt
unterschiedliche elemente das eine ist
zb bekämpfung von steuerbetrug deswegen
so richtig dass digital konzern endlich
vernünftig besteuert werden deswegen
will ich geldwäsche und steuerbetrug so
klar bekämpfen und wir müssen aber auch
dafür sorgen dass wir menschen mit
geringen einkommen entlasten kinder aus
der armut holen und dafür schlage ich
als gegenfinanzierung vor den
einkommenssteuersatz ab 100000 euro
leicht zu erhöhen und das betrifft dann
keine unternehmen deswegen ist es
einfach falsch was sie auch darstellen
den einkommenssteuersatz von menschen
mit viel geld zu erhöhen und dass wir
eine vermögensbesteuerung prüfen damit
wir dafür sorgen dass die länder mehr
geld für die bildung haben weil man kann
sich nicht hinstellen und sagen bildung
ist total wichtig aber das geld stellen
wir dafür nicht bereit und das gehört
für mich zu einer ehrlichen politik dazu
wie hier mal sagen dass das beiden der
grundfehler ist zu glauben wenn man die
wirtschaft abwürgt und steuern erhöht
dass man am ende mehr geld einnimmt und
dass wir nicht in einem internationalen
wettbewerb mehr stehen auch bei der
körperschaftsteuer die unternehmen
zahlen müssen das ist für einen
finanzminister auch eine erstaunliche
aussage denn natürlich überlegen
unternehmen so investieren wir auch
innerhalb der europäischen union
und wenn wir dann viele vorschriften
viel bürokratie es immer komplizierter
machen und dazu noch die steuern erhöhen
wird dass arbeitsplätze in unserem land
gefährden und bei der vermögenssteuer
weiß jeder was heißt das denn auf
deutsch es gibt ein vermögen was jemand
besitzt und dann kommt der finanzbeamte
und beginnt das zu errechnen das
aktienpaket das sparbuch das geht ja nur
einfach aber den schreibtisch oder das
bild an der wand oder dieses und jenes
und weil es so kompliziert es hat das
verfassungsgericht gesagt das ist nicht
gerecht machbar wie es bisher gemacht
hat die regierung von gerhard schröder
hat deshalb keine vermögenssteuer unter
ihrer beteiligung mehr erhoben weil es
ein so riesiger bürokratischer aufwand
ist wenn der in jedem wollen die einfuhr
nach vorne geguckt und jetzt kommt
dieses wieder aus der kiste
keine frage warum wollen sie die aus der
kiste hinsehen er schaut es kurze
antwort ist ja schon gesagt haben wir
müssen was tun für die bildung es geht
um einnahmen für die länder wir haben
diese steuer gehabt über viele viele
jahre und jahrhunderte tatsächlich ist
sie erhoben worden sie es noch in der
ganzen regierungszeit von herrn kohl
erhoben worden das ist das ganze
wirtschaftswunder in deutschland mit
dieser steuer möglich gewesen spricht
also wenig dagegen wenn wir jetzt etwas
mehr geld für bildung und polizei in den
ländern haben dass das für unsere
wirtschaft schlecht wäre aber wenn jetzt
noch ein hinweis wichtig bei der
diskussion über globale verständigung
zur besteuerung die ich eben geschildert
habe die uns ja hilft als land weil wir
nicht mehr diesen druck ausgesetzt sind
kommt ja auch heraus dass viele länder
von denen man das gar nicht gedacht hat
jetzt darüber nachdenken ihre steuern
sogar anzuheben was für
unternehmenssteuern keiner von uns
vorschlägt wenn ich das richtig sehe
also zum beispiel sind die bis
großbritannien dabei jetzt das zu machen
die konservative regierung die usa
diskutieren das gerade mit ihrem
parlament der präsident biden hat das
vorgeschlagen wenn wir unseren guten
moderaten weg weitergehen dann können
wir unser land finanzieren aber es wird
nicht gehen mit steuergeschenken für
leute die sehr sehr viel geld verdienen
das an so zusammenhalt zustande zu
bringen was wir brauchen und die
investitionen zu finanzieren die wir für
die zukunft
machen
das einen punkt und schauen es noch
einmal die zeiten an die tatsächlich
relativ nahe beieinander sind mit einem
kleinen vorsprung aber
den werden wir jetzt nicht mehr komplett
ausgeglichen kriegen denn wir kommen zu
dem schluss gekommen ist und so den
anschluss statements die reihenfolge
haben sie vorher ausgelost untereinander
es wird beginnen mit jetzt nochmal einem
einminütigen
vortrag
archive zuschauerinnen und zuschauer wir
drei haben jetzt 90 minuten diskutiert
aber es geht nicht um uns es geht um sie
es geht um vertrauen ich vertraue
unserem land unseren arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmern den unternehmern den
gewerkschaften den forscherinnen und
wissenschaftlern dass sie unser land
stark machen können
ich garantiere ihnen
als bundeskanzler sie können mir
vertrauen das ich bürokratie abschaffe
dass ich nicht gängeln dass ich sie
machen lasse dass wir ihnen nicht
vorschreiben
wie sie zu denken haben und wie sie zu
reden haben und wie sie zu leben haben
und so können wir es gemeinsam schaffen
ein klimaneutrales industrieland zu
werden ein land wirtschaftlich stark
sozial
und sicher dafür steht die union dafür
will ich als bundeskanzler arbeiten will
ein bundeskanzler des vertrauens werden
und darauf für bitte ich um ihr
vertrauen vielen dank und als nächste
ist annalena baerbock an der reihe
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer sie
haben die wahl schaffen wir einen echten
aufbruch oder verharren wir im weiter so
die nächste regierung ist die letzte die
noch aktiv einfluss auf die klimakrise
nehmen kann und ich bin zutiefst davon
überzeugt wir können das das ist eine
riesenchance für unser land für ein
gesundes und gutes leben für eine starke
wirtschaft mit sicheren arbeitsplätzen
für einen echten sozialen zusammenhalt
das ist die aufgabe unserer zeit die
aufgabe meiner generation
unsere kinder unsere enkel sondern sich
fragen müssen warum habt ihr nichts
getan sondern wie habt ihr das geschafft
dafür trete ich an als ihre
kanzlerkandidatin dafür stehen wir grün
für eine moderne regierung die handelt
bevor es zu spät ist sie entscheiden
deutschland kann so viel mehr
dank an annalena baerbock olaf scholz
mit seinem schlussstatement
es ist jetzt eine entscheidung über die
zukunft deutschlands zu treffen und wir
haben gesehen dass unser land kann
solidarität haben wir gezeigt bei der
bekämpfung der korona krise solidarität
haben wir zu stande gebracht jetzt wo es
darum geht den zu helfen die opfer der
flut geworden sind in
nordrhein-westfalen rheinland-pfalz und
einigen anderen landstrichen unseres
landes und diese solidarität dieser
zusammenhalt das brauchen wir auch für
die zukunft deshalb setze ich mich dafür
ein dass in dieser gesellschaft wieder
mehr respekt herrscht respekt vorleben
und vor jeder dass wir dafür sorgen dass
jede berufliche leistung dass jede
lebensleistung anerkannt wird nicht nur
während der kroner krise sondern auch
danach und das heißt auch dass
diejenigen die heute wenig verdienen
besser bezahlt werden müssen dass wir
ein mindestlohn von 12 euro bekommen und
stabile renten die es gibt wenn man für
die sozialdemokratische partei stimmt
und gleichzeitig geht es um deutschlands
industrielle zukunft ob wir jetzt ganz
schnell im nächsten jahr alle
notwendigen entscheidungen treffen damit
deutschland die wirtschaftliche kraft
entfaltet auch in zehn 20 30 jahren noch
gute arbeitsplätze zu haben und damit
gleichzeitig den menschengemachten
klimawandel aufhalten können große
aufgaben zu denen unser land aber fähig
ist ich möchte ihnen dafür als
bundeskanzler dienen und bitte sie
deshalb um die stimme das für die
sozialdemokratische partei
dank an olaf scholz und nun überhaupt
den drei kandidaten und kandidatinnen
für diese sendung heute abend ihnen
danken wir für ihre aufmerksamkeit liebe
zuschauer es geht natürlich im programm
weiter genau und wer von den
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern am meisten
von der einen oder dem anderen überzeugt
worden ist das erfahren sie bei ard und
zdf jetzt direkt im anschluss da gibt es
nämlich nicht nur analysen sondern auch
blitzumfragen und ergebnisse zu eben
dieser frage das war es von uns einen
schönen abend vielen dank nochmal und
sie bleiben bitte schön gesund und sie
gehen wählen in 14 tagen
[Musik]
ja und damit willkommen zurück zur zdf
heute live hier können sie ganz genau
wie gerade schon genannt auch die
blitzumfragen und die analysen
mitverfolgen und noch besser hier können
sie nämlich ihre fragen und kommentare
direkt mit in die sendung einbringen
wenn sie und ihre youtube nutzen und
nutzt dann einmal bitte auf refresh
gehen und die seite neu laden
damit sie und ihr auch die kommentare
nutzen könnt und wie gewohnt die
eingeblendete e mail adresse nutzen wenn
ihr und sie dies hätte erfreute app
nutzt und ansonsten natürlich auch gerne
über facebook mitmachen tja 95 minuten
entry l viele themen wurden angesprochen
vom mieten deckel über die
finanzskandale im finanzministerium oder
auch in der vergangenheit von olaf
scholz corona war ein thema wir werden
das alles in der analyse hier besprechen
und mit dabei ist unter anderem unserer
hauptstadt korrespondent in stark unter
labbadia konnte was ist dein aller
erster eindruck direkt nach dem ende des
drittels
also vor allem dass hier drei menschen
gestanden haben die sich alle noch im
rennen sehen die jetzt angesichts der
immer noch relativ engen umfragezahlen
und auch der unentschlossenen in diesem
land sagen es lohnt sich noch einmal
sehr zu kämpfen und alle haben noch
einmal den anspruch darauf erhoben eine
bundesregierung führen zu wollen und
haben sich da überhaupt nichts geschenkt
teilweise hatte ich den eindruck dass es
über über einige strecken eher ein duell
gewesen ist wo sich vor allem an den
laschet und olaf scholz
gegenseitig doch ganz schön angegangen
sind aber dann gab hatte annalena
baerbock auch immer wieder momente in
denen sie gerade die lücken in diesen
streitigkeiten in diesen
auseinandersetzungen genutzt hat um für
sich noch einmal themen zu benennen und
auch nach vorne zu schauen dadurch immer
wieder zu signalisieren wir streiten
zwei miteinander die miteinander regiert
haben und an denen ich noch kritik habe
und ich biete jetzt mal ein
zukunftsprogramm an das stand mir heute
abend so ihr konzept gewesen zu sein um
sich dann noch im gespräch zu halten
also das war ein sehr bewegtes trial in
dem alle doch noch einmal sehr nach
vorne gegangen wenn wir auf die inhalte
gucken an welcher stelle
hattest du den eindruck können welche
kandidaten am besten punkten ihre
eigenen punkte setzen
das ist mir heute abend tatsächlich
manchmal nicht ganz klar strukturiert
gewesen weil wir eine sehr große brand
bandbreite gewesen haben an themen die
dadurch geackert worden sind tatsächlich
nochmal man hat auch gesehen dass alle
sattelfest gewesen sind bei allen themen
natürlich haben alle drei dann immer
noch einmal versucht ihre punkte
hervorzuheben annalena baerbock
natürlich beim klimawandel noch einmal
zu sagen hier stehen zwei die haben in
den letzten jahren mit dafür gesorgt
dass nicht das umgesetzt worden ist was
ich demnächst umsetzen würde armin
laschet hat immer wieder betont dass es
ihm um wirtschaft steuern um das jetzt
habe ich den begriff vergessen den er
hier immer wieder immer wieder verwendet
hat um die entfesselung geht das war der
begriff der von ihm auch in den letzten
tagen sehr sehr häufig gehört haben und
olaf scholz ist heute sehr oft in der
defensive gewesen weil er zum teil auch
von zwei seiten angegriffen worden ist
das hat man vor allem am anfang gemerkt
als es um die vorwürfe ging dass er sich
in dem zusammenhang mit ermittlungen mit
staatsanwaltschaftlichen ermittlungen
nicht nicht so verantwortlich gezeigt
hat wie man das erwarten würde so hat es
zumindest
wir werden genau diesen punkt an nachher
auch noch mal im faktencheck überprüfen
hier in der sendung und allah kurzer
blick in die chats hier sagt normiert
über youtube erscheint hat mal wieder so
gar nicht überzeugt also da hat jemand
nicht wirklich jemanden dazu gewinnen
können marlon schreibt auch ich glaube
über youtube mich hat nicht wirklich
einer überzeugt sie waren alle nur so
lala also da ist auch jemand wenig
begeistert und das was du gerade
angesprochen hast diese einschätzung
teilt auch mister los gravity das tri l
war für frau beerbach relativ einfach da
der großteil des tri ace eine arzt
einander setzung zwischen scholz und
laschet war wer denn nun am meisten
punkten konnte das wird interessant sein
zu sehen auch in den blitzumfragen die
wir hören werden eine sache wollen wir
an der stelle mal raus greifen nämlich
eine frage die wir zum ende erwartet
haben die aber gleich am anfang gestellt
und beantwortet wurde nämlich die nach
möglichen koalitionen
eines ist klar für uns wir werden auf
keinen fall mit der linken koalieren wir
werden auf keinen fall mit der fdp
koalieren wir werden mit denen nicht mal
reden wir werden nicht kooperieren und
demokraten untereinander müssen nach der
wahl reden und wir kämpfen um platz eins
wir haben die meisten schnittmengen
gerade in diesen jahren links panzer ein
bereich mit der spd mit der linkspartei
auch das habe ich ja mehrfach deutlich
gemacht ich bin von herzen pro
europäerin ich bin davon überzeugt die
nächste bundesregierung muss eine aktive
außenpolitik betreiben sich nicht
wegducken und die linke hat mit der
letzten entscheidung auch mit blick auf
afghanistan deutlich gemacht dass sie
diese internationale verantwortung nicht
tragen wer in deutschland regieren will
muss klare positionen haben er muss sich
bekennen zur transatlantischen
zusammenarbeit man muss klar sagen dass
die nato für unsere sicherheit
unverzichtbar ist und dass wir unsere
verpflichtungen im bündnis erfüllen
müssen er muss sich klar zu einer
starken souverän europäischen union
bekennen und das will ich auch sagen da
gehört natürlich gerade auch jetzt wo
die zeiten so schwierig sind will ich
das sagen zu dass man auch in der lage
sein muss
heilung zu treffen die zum beispiel
bedeuten dass deutsche soldaten in
anderen ländern zum beispiel im rahmen
eines mandats im rahmen eines mandats
der vereinten nationen oder der nato
tätig sind
hersteller die frage nach der koalition
und nach einer möglichen koalition mit
der linkspartei die beschäftigt ja viele
seid also vor allem in den letzten tagen
vor allem und das ist was worauf viele
hauptstadt journalistinnen und
journalisten immer wieder versuchen eine
ganz klare antwort zu kriegen was ist
sein eindruck wie ist das dieses mal
gelungen
die klare antwort hat das so nicht
gegeben das war auch nicht wirklich zu
erwarten
olaf scholz hat an denen die frage ja
meistens gerichtet wird und
hauptsächlich gerichtet wird hat noch
einmal ganz klar gesagt wo seine roten
linien lieben und jetzt habe ich hier
einen anderen ton auf dem ohr aber ich
glaube das liegt nicht an uns
und die genau ist halten sich momentan
eigentlich alle immer alle optionen
offen versuchen klar zu machen wo sie
ihre grenzen sehen wo sie sich gar nicht
hin bewegen wollen wenn es nicht anders
geht aber es wissen eben auch alle es
werden möglicherweise schwierige
koalitionsbildung prozesse werden man
kann nach jetzigem stand nur einen
dreier koalitionen tatsächlich eine
regierung bilden und dann muss man sich
eben doch einiges offen halten das ist
auch viel taktisches verhalten
und dann gebe ich dir die möglichkeit
dein ohr zu sortieren ich hoffe du hörst
mich wieder und niemand anderen und
nehme an dieser stelle noch jemanden mit
ins boot der auch schon vor der sendung
mit in der sendung waren nämlich mit
rottmann bekannt als mister ein bisschen
to go es ist schon ein bisschen spät vor
ihm motto du hast die sendung auch mit
uns mit verfolgt und ich möchte dir
direkt eine frage stellen die
fabian informiert über youtube fragte
zdf- heute -nachrichten war dass die
trendwende oder die trendfortsetzung was
ist seine einschätzung
tendenziell eher eine trendfortsetzung
das ist auch das was ich in den
kommentaren widerspiegelt die ich
während des drehs verfolgt dabei twitter
bei facebook bei instagram teilweise
auch da hatte ich den eindruck dass die
leute schon vorher eine meinung hatten
die sich auch bestätigt hat im großen
und ganzen ich schiele und ich hoffe ich
nehme euch jetzt nichts vorweg schon mit
halbem auge auf das zdf programm und
sehe im politbarometer beziehungsweise
von matthias fornoff auch zahlen die das
auch ein bisschen unterstreichen außer
bei annalena baerbock da gibt es ein
paar kleinere abweichungen die hat wohl
besser als erwartet abgeschnitten
zumindest laut den ersten trends und das
ist auch genau das was ich im netz
wahrgenommen hat das also viele die
schon eine bestimmte meinung vorher
hatten diese meinung bestätigt bekommen
haben und dass sich da wenig in eine
richtung bewegt hat wir schauen gleich
auf die zahlen haben das große glück
dass wir nicht nur die zahlen haben
sondern auch matthias fornoff direkt bei
uns in der sendung der bei uns mehr als
noch im zdf-hauptprogramm auch in die
tiefe gehen kann was die analyse angeht
deshalb bleiben wir erst noch mal hier
in dieser runde nicht höre wir können zu
matthias rüber gehen weil historische
gehört habe und da ist man hier schon
sagt aber ich glaube wenn matthias sagt
dass es niemanden gibt der ihn fragt
dann kann nämlich noch nicht hören oder
hörte mich jetzt doch hallo matthias
schönen guten abend nach berlin
ich würde sagen das sieht zwar gut aus
40 aber noch nicht so gut an deshalb
gehen wir noch mal zurück zum mirko
drotschmann und deiner analyse mirco
viele userinnen und user haben auch das
gefühl dass es am ende eher ein duell
als 1 tl war das hat er auch schon kund
aller gerade schon gesagt wie schätzt du
die rolle von annalena baerbock ein hat
die davon profitieren können wenn zwei
sich streiten freut sich der dritte oder
ist sie eher in den hintergrund gerückt
weil die beiden ihr am ende die show
gestohlen haben ja ich glaube schon dass
er heute punkten konnte weil sie aus der
opposition attackieren konnte und das
auch gemacht hat immer wieder sie konnte
sagen ihr beiden seiten parteien die an
der regierung beteiligt sind und warum
habt ihr es in den vergangenen jahren
nicht besser gemacht und diesen elfmeter
hat sie die auch immer wieder verwandeln
können warin faktensicher muss man auch
sagen aber tatsächlich
wirkte sie so ein bisschen deplatziert
manchmal weil das war ein duell scholz
gegen laschet und sie wirklich
buchstäblich zwischen den stühlen
gestanden oder zwischen den stehpulten
genauer gesagt und hatte nach meinem
eindruck auch immer so bist du versucht
zu vermitteln zwischen den positionen
aber es ist ja auch schon absehbar dass
wenn olaf scholz mit der spd am schluss
wirklich vorne liegt nach der
bundestagswahl dass die grünen an der
regierung beteiligt sein werden deshalb
waren die breitseiten gegen die spd
jetzt deutlich geringer von annalena
baerbock als die gegen die union also da
hat man schon gesehen wo die prioritäten
liegen hat dich die themenauswahl ein
bisschen überrascht also sowohl die
quantität das cml kollegen so viele
fragen eingebracht haben vom mieten
deckel bis zum comic skandal bis zum zum
zum inhalt also dass es so viele viele
verschiedene dinge waren über die heute
abend gesprochen wurde und glaubst du
dass es vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu
komplex war für viele um sich dann doch
eine meinung bilden zu können
die zweite frage zuerst zu beantworten
ja das war definitiv mein eindruck das
hätte man sicher noch ein bisschen
niedrigschwelliger gestalten können es
war ja wirklich von der ersten bis zur
letzten minute auf einem sehr hohen
niveau was den thematischen anspruch
angeht ich fand das sehr spannend aber
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass leute die
mit politik nicht so viel am hut haben
und die sich mit politik vielleicht alle
vier jahre beschäftigen wenn der wahl
ist er zwischendurch mal ausgestiegen
sind aber das haben solche duelle oder
trelle immer wieder mit sich gebracht
das ist schwierig den spagat zu finden
man hätte vielleicht hier und da das
ganze noch auf eine etwas menschlicher
ebene bringen können mit dem einen oder
anderen ein spieler mit paar betroffenen
schicksalen die da noch mit hätten rein
genommen werden können aber das sagt
sich hinterher immer leichter meckern
kann man kann man hinterher immer ist
wie beim fußballspiel gibt es auch 80
millionen bundestrainer das so will ich
da auch gar nicht so viel schelte
betreiben was mir sehr gut gefallen hat
war tatsächlich das was du auch gerade
angesprochen hat es die die große
thematische bandbreite für meinen
geschmack war es am anfang ein bisschen
zu viel gerede über mögliche koalition
und einzelne personen die da eine rolle
spielen ich wäre gerne früher auf
zukunftsthemen gegangen auf das thema
klimawandel auf das thema
digitalisierung das sind die drängenden
themen den hätte ich auch ein bisschen
mehr zeit eingeräumt aber letztendlich
fand ich es gut dass dann doch so viele
themen stattgefunden haben und man da in
guten eindruck bekommen konnte wie die
einzelnen kandidaten positioniert sind
dann möchte ich an der stelle gerne zu
hause alle aufrufen schreibt uns ihre
und eure kommentare wisst ihr nach
diesem trio leer wenn ihr wählen sollte
habt ihr nach diesem abend eine
wahlentscheidung getroffen habt ihr sie
vielleicht geändert das ist absolut
nicht repräsentativ wasser zurückkommt
aber sicherlich sehr interessant und wo
wir schon beim thema zahlen sind jetzt
ist er da matthias fornoff ist uns
zugeschaltet aus berlin kann uns hören
dass dollar bei sehr guten namen halo
matthias wir sind gespannt was die
umfragedaten hergeben aber natürlich
müssen wir erstmal gucken das ist eine
blitzumfrage die trägt den namen nicht
zu unrecht bevor wir auf die zahlen
gucken wie valide sind diese daten denn
jetzt naja diese zahlen die die
forschungsgruppe wahlen in der tat bis
vor wenigen minuten für uns erhoben hat
telefonisch die sind schon repräsentativ
und zwar für die wahlberechtigten
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer der sendung
nicht für alle wahlberechtigten in
deutschland logischerweise da die fragen
sicher auf dem fernseh dreikampf
beziehen und wer es nicht gesehen hat
der kann es auch nicht beurteilen die
zahlen die ich jetzt zeige bezieht sich
übrigens auf die erste hälfte des tv elz
also die ersten rund 45 minuten und da
gehen wir gleich mal in die erste grafik
in die vielleicht entscheidende wer hat
sich bisher am besten geschlagen armin
laschet sagen 16 prozent olaf scholz 34
prozent annalena baerbock 26 prozent
kein unterschied finden 22 prozent die
reihenfolge also zur halbzeit des trios
scholz vor berbalk vor laschet jetzt
gucken wir mal nicht vergleichen sondern
auf die kandidaten und die kandidatin
einzeln haben die erwartungen erfüllt
oder übererfüllt und da sehen werden
wenn man alle grafiken gleichzeitig
hochfahren dann sehen wir bei armin
laschet und olaf scholz die blauen
balken weit oben mehrheitlich sagen die
leute mit 57 beziehungsweise 59 prozent
laschet und shows haben ungefähr so
abgeschnitten wie wir das auch erwartet
haben der große unterschied dann zur
annalena baerbock da sagen 44 prozent
das ist der grüne balken sie hat besser
abgeschnitten als wir gedacht hätten
dass alles wie gesagt zur halbzeit des
trios und jetzt mal gucken wir uns nach
allen letzte grafik an mit den profilen
die oft hinweise darauf liefern woran es
denn liegt dass die zahlen so zustande
kam wer war am glaubwürdigsten daliegt
scholz kurz vor baerbock und armin
laschet relativ abgeschlagen wer war am
sympathischsten olaf scholz mit ein
bisschen mehr abstand 36 prozent vor
annalena baerbock 29 auch da armin
laschet mit zwölf prozent derzeit
schwach wer zeigte am meisten
sachverstand und das ist ein eindeutiges
bild für olaf scholz 45 prozent nennen
ihn nur 16% laschet und 13 prozent der
berg und man muss jetzt einfach klar
sagen die forschungsgruppe wahlen führt
weiterhin hunderte von telefonaten
repräsentativ ausgewählt in deutschland
unter wahlberechtigten zuschauerinnen
und zuschauern dieses tv triest damit
wir am ende dann ein endergebnis haben
auch von eindrücken der leute die das
komplette training gesehen haben also
ein paar verschiebungen und bewegungen
kann es schon noch gehen super vielen
dank für den moment matthias dann hören
hoffentlich
danke für den moment und später weiter
mit der analyse bild stadt bonn hat
energy in berlin und mirko drotschmann
unterland zunächst zu dir nach der
draufsicht auf diese zahlen die frage
nach gewinnern und verlierern ist zu
kurz gegriffen eigentlich nach einem
solchen duell tree l
trotzdem wenn du die zahlen sie ist
inwiefern siehst du da dinge bestätigt
und in niefern bist du an manchen
stellen überrascht
[Applaus]
ich habe die zahlen liegen ja im grunde
genommen in dem trend den wir jetzt in
den letzten wochen auch gesehen haben
und bestätigen noch mal dass sich für
urlaubs zumindest die taktik bewährt hat
möglichst ich sage mal inhaltlich ruhig
auf seinem punkt stehen zu lassen sich
nicht aus der ruhe bringen zu lassen da
ist er heute ja doch noch mal häufiger
angegangen worden und auch sehr
angriffsfreudig sowohl von annalena
baerbock als auch von der stadt zum teil
in die zange genommen worden aber
offensichtlich haben die zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer den eindruck gehabt dass
er das auch anständig pariert hat sonst
wären die zahlen sicherlich nicht so wie
sie jetzt sind und für armin laschet ist
das jetzt zumindest nach diesen
allerersten zahlen die man ja
tatsächlich noch mit vorsicht genießen
muss und noch mal die weiteren fragen
abwarten sollte ist das nicht die
erhoffte große trendwende zumindest
nicht bei den zuschauerinnen und
zuschauern denn darauf hatte laschet und
hatten seine hatte seine partei auch
gesetzt dass er nach dem auftritt
gestern bei der csu
csu heute noch mal einen drauf legen
kann und dass er die stimmung auch
wenden kann dass das jetzt der auftakt
ist zu einem grossen aufholen rennen
nochmal in den letzten zwei wochen das
kommt jetzt aus der ersten
momentaufnahme so nicht wirklich aus
dann schauen wir mal auf das was er im
netz so an reaktionen da war mirco du
hast das auch verfolgt wir haben so ein
paar sachen ausgewählt die wir auf
twitter gefunden haben ich hoffe wir
können das jetzt
zeigen und vorlegen wir sehen hier ein
tweet thomas lückerath schreibt
sonntagabend 20 40 in den ersten 25
minuten treille ging es um weniger
gesellschaftlich relevante themen als
sonst in jedem tatort dafür mehr
beziehungsdrama als bei rosamunde
pilcher dann haben wir hier gefunden ein
user dem man ganz klar der spd verorten
kann das lautem poltern gerade war
friedrich merz der auch versucht hat
aufs podium zu kommen markus söder hat
er übrigens auch vielleicht eine rolle
gespielt schreibt jemand anders der
hätte vielleicht auch gerne mitgemacht
und hier ernst gemeinte frage was soll
dann eher unpolitischer bürger bis jetzt
wirklich inhaltlich ist von diesem trio
mit nehmen schreibt ein user mirko das
ist eigentlich genau das gegenteil von
dem was du gerade gesagt hast denn du
kannst das ist sehr viele inhalte waren
und dass man eigentlich relativ viel
mitnehmen konnte oder
ja viele inhalte auf jeden fall
zumindest dann ja in den letzten beiden
dritteln des duells am anfang wie gesagt
ging es um koalitionen und personen aber
was ich auch gesagt hatte war dass es
für politisch weniger informierte
menschen vermutlich dann doch eher ein
impuls war den fernseher auf ein anderes
programm zu schalten weil man
überfrachte wurde ich fand die auswahl
und die ja die variante themen gut aber
die tiefe war mir an der ein oder andere
stelle dann doch ein bisschen zu extrem
also ich hätte mir ist ein bisschen
niedrigschwelliger gewünscht ein paar
leichte elemente auch noch mit drin um
eben alle leute mitzunehmen auch
diejenigen die nicht jeden tag die
zeitung lesen oder fernsehen schauen mit
politischen talkshows und anderen dingen
also da kann ich diesen kommentar sehr
gut verstehen der übrigens von dario
schrank kommt der meines wissens nach in
bundesschulen
bundesschülervertretung engagiert ist
also da doch für eine große gruppe
junger menschen auch spricht und sich
auch sicherlich sehr dafür interessiert
hat war es die kandidaten und die
kandidatin zum thema impfpflicht bei
corona gesagt haben das haben wir uns
noch mal an ich
würde mir wünschen und das ist jetzt in
der letzten woche durch die
bundesregierung beschlossen worden dass
bestimmte berufsgruppen dem arbeitgeber
offen legen müssen ob sie geimpft sind
oder nicht ganz vertraulich aber man
muss in einem krankenhaus in einem
pflegeheim wissen sind die mitarbeiter
geimpft und die mitarbeiterinnen oder
nicht ich hätte mir ein anderes als
nehmen dass wir das noch weitere berufe
aus denen das war nicht möglich aber um
gesundheitsschutz im betrieb zu erhalten
findet muss jeder das offenlegen wenn
wir jetzt erleben dass er gerade mit
blick auf pflegeeinrichtung und
krankenhäuser zu der situation kommen
dass nicht genug beschäftigte geimpfte
sind dann sollte aus meiner sicht diese
diese frage durchaus angegangen werden
das gleiche gilt sie wären für eine
impfpflicht für
einzelne berufsgruppen wir haben das ja
zum beispiel bei der bundeswehr auch ist
ja nicht was was ganz komplett neu ist
und wenn wir jetzt die situation haben
dass wir zur auswahl haben schließen
wieder kitas und schulen gehen wir in
den nächsten lockdown dann muss aus
meiner sicht diese frage auch impfungen
für einzelne berufsgruppen angegangen
werden und das ist vor allen dingen auch
der bildungsbereich den wir da ganz klar
ins auge fassen des erstens bin ich
gegen eine impfpflicht aber ich bin
dafür dass wir alle überzeugen und dabei
hilft das was wir jetzt gesetz gewünscht
auf den weg gebracht haben nämlich dass
in bestimmten berufsbereichen gefragt
werden kann ob man sich impfen lassen
das fanden sich alle gut aber ich fand
das richtig ich habe mich sehr dafür
eingesetzt dass wir diese möglichkeit
geschaffen und das wird dann auch dazu
führen dass wir einen besseren überblick
haben und das und damit umgehen kann ich
glaube wir werden feststellen dass sehr
viele dort wo es darauf ankommt auch von
ihrer möglichkeit gebrauch gemacht haben
sich impfen zu lassen
das herunter wenn ich das richtig
interpretiere dann geht annalena
baerbock am weitesten an dieser stelle
und sagt bestimmte berufsgruppen sollten
tatsächlich einer impfpflicht
unterliegen
stößt sie damit ins horn derer die sagen
sie es die grünen wieder verbieten
vorschreiben und wird ihr das am ende
vielleicht zum nachteil gereichen
christina jetzt haben wir hier leider
gerade wieder ein bisschen tonprobleme
ich habe deine frage am ende nicht ganz
verstanden könnte ist die wahrscheinlich
der trend hashtag des heutigen abends
wie war die frage hier half inters ort
armin laschet in der in der sendung
aufgestellt wir können das hier gerne
nochmal nachspielen ich hoffe du kannst
mich jetzt hören also ja ich kann nicht
hören der ton ist so leider nicht nicht
besonders gut ich weiß dass ging um die
impfpflicht und das annalena baerbock an
dieser stelle tatsächlich die
weitergehende forderung gestellt hat ich
finde das war eine der passagen an denen
man gesehen hat dass es einfach für
jemanden der aus der opposition heraus
wahlkampf macht deutlich einfacher ist
als für die beiden deren parteien ja
immerhin mit regiert haben und auch
vieles mit zu verantworten haben auch
die grünen haben in der pandemie auf
bund länder ebene tatsächlich vieles
mitbestimmt weil sie an vielen
landesregierungen beteiligt sind aber
eben bei dieser umfrage
wäre das eine wäre das eine bundes frage
so weit ich soweit ich da jetzt das aus
dem stegreif sagen kann und da konnte
sie natürlich auch ein bisschen besser
aufspielen das ist aber auch eine heikle
frage die er in den vergangenen wochen
immer wieder
unterschiedlich beantwortet worden ist
auch sehr zurückhaltend beantwortet
worden ist auch von annalena baerbock ja
nicht pauschal mit alt mit einer
forderung nach impfpflicht sondern für
bestimmte berufsgruppen und die anderen
die sich zurückhaltend verweisen da auch
immer wieder darauf dass es
verfassungsrechtlich gar nicht so
einfach sei das dann durchzusetzen wenn
man überhaupt darüber diskutieren wollte
dann geben wir nochmal zu mirco mit
einer frage die ich gerne aufnehmen
möchte oliver sagt über youtube ich
denke dass letztlich olaf scholz
gewinnen wird allerdings könnte im
letzten moment noch laschet aufholen was
glaubst du was werden die nächsten zwei
wochen bringen
ja das ist wirklich eine sehr gute frage
der blick in die glaskugel der berühmte
ich denke auch die zahlen die wir von
matthias von gesehen haben zeigen dass
es da einen trend gibt der sich auch
nicht durch dieses trio wirklich hat
beilegen lassen auch wenn es erst mal
die halbzeitbilanz industrie es war aber
ich sage jetzt einfach mal voraus dass
es auch in der end bilanz nicht
großartig anders aussieht und dass es
wird sehr schwierig sein wird das ruder
nochmal rumzureißen in eine andere
richtung zu gehen wenn man einmal einen
ruf hat dann ist es schwer den wieder
wegzubekommen deshalb würde ich jetzt
mal prognostizieren dass der trend den
wir gerade erleben wenn du jetzt noch
was ganz unvorhergesehenes dazwischen
kommt sich fortsetzen würde ich glaube
dass es zwischen union und spd ein
bisschen enger wird vielleicht um 1 2%
am schluss aber ansonsten denke ich mal
hat dieses thema jetzt nicht dazu
beigetragen das ruder herumzureißen und
ich habe mich ehrlich gesagt auch ein
bisschen gewundert nach dem ersten trial
hat armin laschet ja
auch in den zahlen erkennen können dass
diese dieser modus auf angriff zu gehen
offenbar nicht so wirklich gut an kamen
bei den zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
trotzdem hat er das beim zweiten mal
jetzt wieder gemacht wäre ich sein
berater gewesen hätte ich gesagt wir
versuchen aus diesen fehlern zu lernen
und machen es diesmal anders das hat er
nicht gemacht und die zahlen sind
dementsprechend
vielen dank mirko drotschmann für diese
analyse vielen dank als container
banerjee nach berlin und wir machen hier
im studio weiter mit professor jürgen
meyer von der universität koblenz-landau
schön dass sie immer noch bei uns sind
dass sie die sendung mitverfolgt haben
für alle die die vorhin noch nicht dabei
waren sie haben eine app entwickelt die
quasi eine echtzeit messung während des
trails macht und gemacht hat sie haben
es beim letzten drittletzten trial auch
schon gemacht und auch schon bei
vorherigen
duellen damals seit 2002 machen sie es
glaube ich richtig diese auftritte
verfolgt was war denn ihr eindruck
welche momente heute abend könnten die
leute auch in ihrer umfrage dazu bewogen
haben ausschläge nach oben oder unten zu
empfinden
also da gibt es ausschläge nach oben und
nach unten aus ganz verschiedenen
motivation für ganz verschiedene
kandidaten ich glaube
der eindeutigste ausschlag nach unten
ist vermutlich das was ja auch schon
angesprochen haben die frage von armin
laschet was denn die frage des
moderators oder der moderatorin war das
sind natürlich dinge die dürfen in so
einem tv-duell nicht passieren da muss
man präsent sein dass das einfach
unabhängig davon warum das jetzt
geschehen ist vielleicht gab es ja auch
technische probleme einfach nicht so
besonders gut das heißt es sind
tatsächlich so ganz kleine dinge die
beiläufig unvorhergesehen passieren die
am ende den ausschlag geben können
absolut und da möchte ich gerne auf die
kollegen die eben gerade schon ein
bisschen die sache reflektiert haben
zurückkommen wir haben ja in solchen
tv-duellen auch immer sehr sehr viele
personen die sich nicht so wahnsinnig
stark für politik interessieren ganz
anders als in anderen formaten zieht so
ziehen solche tv-debatten trainer duelle
so eine gruppe von wählern in hohem maße
an und für die ist das an bestimmten
stellen vielleicht einfach zu
kompliziert zu kleinteilig und dann
werden andere aspekte in den blick
genommen die leichter zu verstehen oder
ja zu bewerten sind und da spielen
solche kleinigkeiten einfach noch alle
dass man sich nicht vorstellen kann wie
ein politiker in seiner runde steht
von der im vorfeld gesagt wird das ist
vielleicht seine allerletzte chance das
ruder herumzureißen und nicht
vollständig fokussiert ist ja also dass
da wäre ich sehr überrascht wenn ich in
den daten die ich morgen hoffentlich
auswerten kann nicht drastischen abfall
nach unten
erkennen würde auf der anderen seite
haben wir sicherlich auch bei olaf
scholz probleme hat probleme gehabt am
anfang des duells ich sage immer aktuell
entschuldigung ich muss mich an diese
trio erst noch gewöhnen
als es wieder um die linke ging und
mögliche koalitionsoptionen das haben
wir schon im trial vor 14 tagen gesehen
dass das eine seiner schwächsten stellen
war die ja dort ja die die zuschauer
dort wahrgenommen haben weil er einfach
nicht klar sagt was er vorhat sich alle
optionen offen hält das ist das ist
schwierig aber auch die
diskussion um seine finanzaffären in der
vergangenheit bzw den umgang mit der
aktuellen durchsuchung seiner behörde
da ist doch sehr unter druck gekommen
von allen seiten und da hat er dann
einfach probleme gehabt die bisherige
strategie die ganz gut funktioniert hat
sich so ein bisschen als amtsinhaber
darzustellen
fortzufahren in diese situation ist er
eigentlich erst so ab minute 25 30
gekommen dass er dann in ein fahrwasser
war wie es vorher gehabt die sendung ist
ja auch erstaunlich lange an diesem
thema hängen geblieben ob das ja auch
gar nicht so sehr ungewöhnlich also
das erstaunt mich persönlich auch ein
bisschen wenn man gerade mal sieht und
sich vor augen hält was so ein tv-duell
oder tv.de elle was solche
diskussionsrunden eigentlich für eine
funktion haben für eine leistung
erbringen sollten da geht es darum
schlaglichtartig die wichtigsten
politikbereiche abzuarbeiten und sich so
lange daran aufzuhalten auch die frage
herr maßen herr palmer welche rolle und
wie man dort in der partei
innerparteilich damit umgegangen ist ich
bin nicht sicher ob das dem wähler in
irgendeiner form wirklich weitergeholfen
hier ist eine frage an sie von dgk über
youtube ob es
ob es aus ihrer sicht erfolgversprechend
ist wenn man einen gegner permanent
aggressiv attackiert ja das ist eine
ganz schwierige frage die im regal
meterweise
universitäts bibliotheken füllt und die
antwort ist man weiß es nicht so genau
grundsätzlich denken die kandidaten und
auch wahlkampfmanager immer dass das
eine sinnvolle strategie wäre weil man
im bestmöglichen fall natürlich am image
des kontrahenten kratzen kann und sich
auf diese art und weise relativ
verbessern kann aber es gibt ganz ganz
viele
fragezeichen und
dinge von von denen diese wirkung von
seiner strategie auch wirklich abhängt
als erstes muss man sagen wenn man die
bürger da fragt wie gut sie das finden
dann sagen die allermeisten bürger das
finde ich eigentlich keine besonders
gute art und weise miteinander umzugehen
ich möchte eigentlich viel lieber von
den kandidaten wissen was sie machen
wollen wenn sie gewählt werden
und das sagt man natürlich in so mit so
einer mit seiner strategie nicht aus
sondern man ja
skizziert was der gegner alles falsch
gemacht hat und wo vielleicht auch
persönliche defizite hatte
und das wird immer vor allen dingen dann
zum problem wenn wir auch zum teil in
dieser in dieser debatte abgeschnitten
sind wenn das sozusagen dirty wird wenn
wirklich auch ja da aussagen getroffen
werden nicht so ein bisschen über die
unter die gürtellinie gehen die
gegenüber verletzten also
armin laschet hat zum beispiel bei der
frage um die finanzskandale
den umgang von olaf scholz und seine
behörde mit der staatsanwaltschaft
kritisiert und hat ihn in der nähe von
populisten autoritären system
gestellt dass es schwierig auf der
anderen seite spricht olaf scholz armin
laschet
ehrlich zu sein und er würde die
tatsachen vertreten würde falsche
behauptungen in die welt setzen also
alles dinge die an der glaubwürdigkeit
des gegenübers kratzen
also von daher gibt es eine ganze menge
risiken die mit dieser strategie
verbunden ich persönlich verstehe nicht
warum armin laschet so agiert ich kann
es verstehen aus der perspektive des
ersten teils da hat er im prinzip eine
fahrtmöglichkeit
angelegt hat sich dafür entschlossen
diesen aggressiven wahlkampf zu führen
und das wäre jetzt wahrscheinlich auch
etwas merkwürdig gewesen wenn er davon
an in dieser sendung abgelassen hätte
und jetzt ja so eine amtsinhaber
strategie was habe ich alles geleistet
und die politischen gegner um mich herum
interessiert mich eigentlich nicht wenn
er so etwas
verfolgt eigentlich ist es ja total
frustrierend wenn man sich das anhört
was sie sagen dass es die meisten
ausschläge gibt wenn es unter die
gürtellinie geht wenn jemand einen
ausrutscher hat wenn es
nebensächlichkeiten sind wir sind ja
eigentlich alle sehr erpicht darauf über
inhalte zu sprechen und das ist ja auch
eine große kritik am wahlkampf viele
sagen es ist alles so oberflächlich es
geht um fußnoten und abgeschrieben und
lacher im hintergrund es muss vielmehr
über die inhalte geredet werden und dann
sehen sie aber an den ergebnissen ihrer
umfrage die meisten ausschläge also das
heißt auch die meisten auswirkungen auf
wahlentscheidungen hat man nicht bei den
inhalten nicht bei den sachthemen
sondern eigentlich bei nebensächlich im
oder ist das jetzt ja sowas gar
negativen ganz verwirrt es nicht sagen
weil man kann ja durchaus sieht man
kritisieren und dabei über inhalte reden
also dann geht es ja tatsächlich nicht
um die person und ihre glaubwürdigkeit
und ihre integrität sondern tatsächlich
um fehlentwicklungen die in der politik
gemacht werden und wie man sie
korrigieren kann und da muss man
natürlich auch ross und reiterin
verantwortliche dafür nennen aber es
gibt natürlich auch wissenschaftliche
gründe warum das so ist warum die
menschen darauf reagieren weil negative
informationen einfach informationsreiche
sind als positive information die
informationen herr scholz zum beispiel
um jetzt mal einen herauszugreifen hat
auch heute wieder seinen job als
minister
gut und fehlerlos gemacht das ist keine
meldung sondern das erwarten ja einfach
ein problem wird es dann wenn er das
eben nicht gemacht hat man sofort im
negativen bereich der eben dann auch
eben entsprechende aufmerksamkeit
generiert die leute hören zu selbst wenn
sie aus der partei von olaf scholz
kommen dass das sozusagen eine panne
eine dna die wir in uns haben
dass wir da eine besondere
aufmerksamkeit draufsetzen aber
natürlich kann man vielleicht noch ein
gedanke
auch mit positiven aussagen
zustimmung generieren und aus der
forschung wissen wir immer dann wenn
solche aussagen fallen ja die praktisch
zustimmungspflichtig sind ja wo wir uns
nicht vorstellen können dass es
irgendjemanden gibt ja keine
vollbeschäftigung möchte kein
umweltschutz möchte
keine
gesundheitssysteme sowie aus dem oder
oder irgendwie gleich heiten in kassel
ungleichheiten in der gesellschaft
abbauen möchte wenn man so etwas
thematisiert und vielleicht auch noch
verbindet mit einer einem einem appell
einem enthusiastischen und wir schaffen
das wir sind irgendwie unsere geschichte
zeigt dass wir aus solchen schwierigen
situation rauskommen und so dann nimmt
man auch relativ viele leute mit und
kann auch über die parteigrenzen hinweg
punkten also hat man kann mit beiden
dingen punkt das ist aber ein sehr
schmaler grat und es ist extrem
schwierig auch in so einem dynamischen
setting wieso einer debatte vorher zu
sagen in welche richtung sich das
entwickler apropos leute mitnehmen und
überzeugen und sich an die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer wenden das
genau es in den schluss date menz
passiert und wir haben die ein bisschen
kondensiert und hier sind sie normal für
sie ich garantiere ihnen
als bundeskanzler sie können mir
vertrauen das ich bürokratie abschaffe
dass ich nicht gängeln dass ich sie
machen lasse dass wir ihnen nicht
vorschreiben
wie sie zu denken haben und wie sie zu
reden haben und wie sie zu leben haben
die nächste regierung ist die letzte die
noch aktiv einfluss auf die klimakrise
nehmen kann und ich bin zutiefst davon
überzeugt wir können das das ist eine
riesenchance für unser land für ein
gesundes und gutes leben für eine starke
wirtschaft mit sicheren arbeitsplätzen
für einen echten sozialen zusammenhalt
das ist die aufgabe unserer zeit die
aufgabe meiner generation solidarität
haben wir gezeigt bei der bekämpfung der
korona krise solidarität haben wir zu
stande gebracht jetzt wo es darum geht
den zu helfen die opfer der flut
geworden sind in nordrhein-westfalen
rheinland-pfalz und einigen anderen
landstrichen unseres landes und diese
solidarität dieser zusammenhalt das
brauchen wir auch für die zukunft
deshalb setze ich mich dafür ein dass in
dieser gesellschaft wieder mehr respekt
herrscht
ja da gab es bei dem einen oder anderen
bei ihnen zum beispiel ein kleines déjà
vu denn vieles aus den statements haben
wir letztes mal auch schon gehört ist
das gut weil sich die botschaft damit
verfestigt oder ist das schlecht weil
man denkt wie ist dann nichts neues
eingefallen also steht der tropfen höhlt
den stein aber natürlich nur dann wenn
das auch wirklich sinn macht und gut ist
bei annalena baerbock olaf scholz haben
wir in großen teilen das gehört dazu vor
14 tagen als schluss statement gehört
haben in leichten variationen aber der
thematische kern und manche aussagen
waren identisch gewesen
und aus unseren ergebnissen diesen
echtzeit messungen wissen wir dass diese
schluss statements eigentlich ganz gut
funktioniert haben
insbesondere bei olaf scholz der auch
über die parteigrenzen hinweg in der
lage war zustimmung zu generieren und
aus psychologischer sicht sagen einige
ja so ein schluss statement ist ganz
besonders wichtig weil es erstens noch
mal so eine debatte zusammenfasst aber
auf der anderen seite möglicherweise
auch das letzte ist was so ein bisschen
im gedächtnis bleibt und dann später in
urteilsbildung einfließt
armin laschet hat anders probiert also
hatte eigentlich all das was er vor 14
tagen gemacht hat und was im übrigen
ganz ganz schlecht gelaufen ist hat noch
nicht mal in der war noch nicht mehr in
der lage seine eigene basis seiner
eigenen anhänger in irgendeiner form
dazu zu bewegen
diesen drehregler in richtung +3 zu
ziehen er hat eigentlich alles
aufgegeben und hat noch mal von vorne
angefangen
er hat diesmal auch ganz im unterschied
zum letzten mal ein bisschen was über
seine inhaltlichen komplexe die ja gerne
angehen möchte so stichwortartig
berichtet
und was mir hängen geblieben ist ist er
ist der satz er möchte der bundeskanzler
des vertrauens werden
ob das gereicht hat sich den wählern so
zu präsentieren dass sie dann auch sagen
ja das ist der mann den ich dort gerne
sehen möchte und die partei die in
regierungsverantwortung
kommen soll das werden die zahlen zeigen
gefühlsmäßig würde ich sagen das ist
einfach schwierig und zu wenig da da da
da muss man ein anderes statement
entwickeln wie es dann ausgeht sehen wir
in zwei wochen wir blicken noch mal auf
die zahlen auch wenn das auf papier
ausgedruckt ist aber es ist besser drauf
gucken noch mal die zahlen
die
wird sehen können hier auch bei der
forschungsgruppe wahlen die sich
umgehört hat und auch da kann man sehen
nach der halbzeit matthias fornoff hat
gerade schon gesagt die meisten punkte
konnte dann doch auch in dieser sendung
wieder olaf scholz machen auch sie an
sie die eigentlich nicht erlaubte aber
dann doch auf der hand liegende frage
wer hat sich am besten geschlagen wer am
wenigsten deckt sich das so mit ihrem
eindruck also man kann zumindest diesmal
festhalten dass am schlechtesten
abgeschnitten
herr laschet hat in den in den finalen
resultaten herz
und berbalk und
scholz haben beide sehr gut
abgeschnitten olaf scholz einen tick
besser
ja das ist so ein bisschen auch die
frage
so ein bisschen geschmackssache würde
ich mal sagen in aus welcher richtung
mit welchem blickt man auf diese debatte
also ich persönlich finde dass annalena
baerbock relativ guten job gemacht hat
sie hat ja die rolle als herausforderung
angenommen und immer wieder aufgezeigt
wo es probleme gab in der
regierungspolitik der letzten jahre und
jahrzehnte aber gleichzeitig auch
sozusagen ein comparatives statement
entwickelt und erläutert wo sie
eigentlich gerne hin möchte deswegen
kann ich gut verstehen dass schon in der
halbzeit umfrage
der balken sie hat eigentlich besser
abgeschnitten als man das erwartet hätte
da relativ hoch war olaf scholz ja er
hat wieder diese situation eingenommen
dass er agiert als wäre er eigentlich
der amtsinhaber und möchte jetzt gerne
wieder gewählt werden und das ist ihm in
der zweiten im zweiten drittel oder den
letzten zwei drittel durch dieser
debatte ziemlich gut gelungen wieder von
daher
wenn man auf seine eigenen erfolge
verweist sich dann auch irgendwie aus
grabenkämpfen hinaus heraushält und
versucht vor allen dingen sich nicht
immer gegen angriffe der gegner
verteidigen zu müssen dann kommt dieses
ergebnis zustande
ja und laschet würde ich sagen die
erwartung erdrücken ihn einfach also
sowohl aus der eigenen reihen als auch
was medial dort entwickelt wird alle
reden davon dass er innerhalb von 90
minuten das ruder oben reißen könnte und
prozentpunkte aufholen kann das ist
schwer für ihn aber man muss auch sagen
dass es so ein bisschen die quadratur
des kreises das war so lang machen er
liegt 4 5 prozentpunkte je nachdem
welche umfrage man sieht hinten dran er
hat eine strategie eingeschlagen die man
eigentlich nicht mehr ändern kann das
problem an der sache
das ebenso mehrparteiensystem ja die
dynamiken doch sehr komplex sind und
anders als zum beispiel den
präsidentiellen system oder weiß ich
wenn ich gewinne verliert automatisch da
andere und hier ist es eben nicht so das
heißt es ist ganz ganz schwer jetzt auch
am ende des wahlkampfs eine strategie zu
entwickeln
wo hat sich nochmal ein bisschen mit
sagt man an den haaren aus dem shop am
schopf ergreifen trotzdem ziehen kann ja
sagt professor jürgen meyer vielen dank
dass sie bei uns wird heute live in der
sendung waren dankeschön wir sind
gespannt auf ihre ergebnisse die dann
morgen im lauf des tages von morgen
spätestens übermorgen alles klar vielen
dank und dann gehen wir noch mal nach
berlin und zwar dorthin wo alissa jung
für uns steht und alisa wie sieht es aus
bei welchen teams wird sekt getrunken
und bei welchen selters
[Applaus]
die app studio ist eine gegenwelt dass
ihr könnt ihr wählen
im studio gibt fällt das ja hier geweckt
tatsächlich und zwar hinter mir bei den
grünen das annalena baerbock gerade
angekommen und eben gerade wurde mit
sekt angestoßen offensichtlich scheint
man hier zufrieden zu sein mit ihrer
performance jetzt ihr könnt das sehen
hier hinter mir stehen sie noch
beisammen annalena baerbock dreht und
gerade den rücken zum dunkelblauen kleid
und hier war man offensichtlich sehr
zufrieden mit ihrer performance für sie
ist als zweites hier angekommen der
erste der tatsächlich aus dem studio kam
bei urlaubs der hat sich zunächst mal
eine currywurst geholt offensichtlich
hatte er hunger wurde dann natürlich wie
jetzt auch annalena baerbock zuvor von
der presse umlagert dann hat lars
klingbeil urlaub stolz in empfang
genommen und sie haben auch erst mal
angestoßen mit einem bier also auch da
wirkte man gelöst und offensichtlich
auch zufrieden aber ich würde das jetzt
auch sehr wundern wenn hier irgendjemand
mit sich selbst jetzt hier nicht einen
zufriedenen eindruck machen würde auf
armin laschet habe ich eben gerade
draußen noch gewartet er scheint der
letzte zu sein der jetzt hier noch dazu
stößt also ihnen habe ich noch nicht
gesehen aber kann sein dass elf geben in
den letzten minuten auch dazu gekommen
dieser konnte man während des tri ace
spüren wie zufrieden oder unzufrieden
die leute vor ort waren mit der
performance oder haben journalistinnen
und journalisten schon erste
einschätzungen abgegeben
während des tri 11 6 war wirklich
ziemlich pokerface angesagt muss man
sagen bei den hier anwesenden
politikerinnen und politikern also sie
haben sich räumlich auch wer verteilt
hier hinter mir in diesem großen
pressezelt gab es also zwei stuhlreihen
gibt es rennt voneinander durch einen
gang auf der einen seite war es dann die
spd auf der anderen seite saßen die
grünen und draußen vor einer leinwand
dies auch noch gab hatte sich dann die
union versammelt und da war tatsächlich
es war überraschender weise relativ
still wenig szenenapplaus manchmal sehr
vereinzelt oder aber jetzt auch wenig
negative reaktionen also da hielt man
sich sehr bedeckt während des nicht ob
einige der politikerinnen und politiker
twittern sehen kritisch das schon also
online hat man seiner kritik ausdruck
verliehen aber hier jetzt selbst im raum
und auch draußen vor dem pressezelt war
tatsächlich ist er sehr ruhig und das
war auch interessant also die kann ihn
in dem fall in die kandidatinnen anderen
in der werbung und auch olaf scholz die
beiden kamen dann war so viel presse
hallo was war jetzt kein tosender jubel
gerade hier passiert hinter mir etwas
und es ist vielleicht da ist armin
laschet vielleicht drehen wir uns ein
wenig mit oder er kommt jetzt auch schon
in unsere richtung also hier könnt ihr
sehen der letzte der noch gefehlt hat in
der runde am ihn nachher kommt und auch
sofort eine presse traube viele fragen
an armin laschet also jetzt wohl in
diesem moment gerade erst eingetroffen
das jetzt wird's hier etwas lauter etwas
mehr um das heißt also er stellt sich
jetzt auch direkt im anschluss noch
einmal den fragen der journalistinnen
und journalisten wasser in eigene
eindruck war
das machen alle drei also sie werden
tatsächlich immer wieder auch von
journalistinnen und journalisten befragt
es gab jetzt aber auch momente da hieß
es damals wir brauchen jetzt auch mal
kurz einen moment für uns zum besprechen
also da suchen sich die drei hier schon
auf ihre momente mit ihren
parteifreundinnen und freunden und jetzt
gerade kann man sehen also armin laschet
im gespräch mit annalena baerbock
tatsächlich auch und olaf scholz sehe
ich jetzt gerade nicht dabei stehen muss
mich noch auf die zehenspitzen
schlechten strich dann mehr aber im
aktuell ist dass armin laschet und
annalena baerbock umringt von der presse
und ihren parteifreunden und hier sehen
wir jetzt armin laschet der das treffe
zelt verlässt
und uns hier freundlich zugelegt hat an
der startposition
wunderbar und wird wird sie auch wieder
ein bisschen lauter
vielen dank also der abend in berlin ist
noch lange nicht zu ende alisa vielen
dank dass du das für uns mitverfolgt hat
dankeschön für diese eindrücke bis
hierhin nach berlin und wir gehen noch
einmal zum mann der zahlen zu matthias
fornoff der jetzt mit der hilfe der
forschungsgruppe wahlen nicht nur die
halbzeit zahlen für uns hatte die hatte
er vorhin jetzt gibt es tatsächlich auch
die ergebnisse für die gesamte länge des
tri ace was hat sich denn da verändert
matthias
für die auswertung dieses tv teams und
wir schauen man auf die erste grafik da
sehen wir wer hat sich beim tv trial am
besten geschlagen 20 prozent sagen jetzt
armin laschet da hatte etwas boden gut
gemacht in der zweiten halbzeit
sozusagen 32 prozent sagen olaf scholz
und annalena baerbock 26 prozent kein
unterschied 21 prozent also die
reihenfolge scholz vor der burg verlasse
die hat sich nicht verändert aber es ist
ein bisschen enger geworden dann schauen
wir uns die drei mal einzeln an wie hat
sind die erwartungen in erfüllung
gegangen oder nicht bei den zuschauern
armin laschet besser als erwartet ein
drittel ist ein gutes drittel 35 prozent
die meisten aber sagen der blaue balken
so wie erwartet bei olaf scholz ist das
noch ausgeprägter 58 prozent sagen das
war mehr oder weniger so wie wir es
erwartet aber auch da 27 prozent die
ihnen besser fanden annalena baerbock
ist da am stärksten 53 prozent die
mehrheit findet sie hat besser
abgeschnitten als man erwartet hat und
die gute nachricht ist natürlich für
alle drei schlechter abgeschnitten hat
so richtig keiner das sagen nur
minderheiten wir schauen jetzt nochmal
auf eine grafik die wir vorher noch
nicht gesehen haben da geht es um die
altersstruktur wir schauen mal bei den
18 bis 34 also bei den jüngeren wer hat
sich da wie geschlagen da sehen wir eine
mehrheit von 52 prozent die annalena
baerbock als siegerin sieht bei den
beiden anderen altersgruppen aber 35 bis
59 jahre und über 60 liegt olaf scholz
vorne hier kam nochmals zu den profilen
um zu verstehen wie solche zahlen
eigentlich zu sein zustandekommen und da
sehen wir wer war am glaubwürdigsten
olaf scholz vor annalena baerbock vor
armin laschet auch da hat laschet ein
bisschen aufgeholt im vergleich zur
ersten halbzeit wer war am
sympathischsten da hat alena berbalk
deutlich zugelegt kommt jetzt auf 39
prozent vor olaf stolz mit 28 und armin
laschet mit 14 prozent und werder
meisten sachverstand gezeigt nach wie
vor olaf scholz mit großem vorsprung hat
aber ein paar punkte weniger als vorhin
armin laschet 21% anderen den am berg
bock 12 prozent
tja interessante zahlen lieber matthias
vielen herzlichen da gar nicht und die
forschungsgruppe wahlen nach berlin und
darüber werden wir hier weiter reden
können und die parteien in der natürlich
auch vielen dank matthias und wir gehen
weiter mit fragen die viele
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
beschäftigen nämlich wer hat denn an
welcher stelle die wahrheit gesagt und
dabei helfen kann uns thomas reichert
der uns zugeschaltet ist auch aus berlin
thomas schön dass du da bist weil es
wirklich viele kommentare in diese
richtung gibt und wir fangen mal an
direkt mit dem beginn der sendung
ziemlich zu beginn und einem großen teil
der sendung der sich ja mit den
finanzskandalen beschäftigt hat mit
comics mit wirecard und aber auch mit
den
staatsanwaltlichen ermittlungen gerade
im bundesfinanzministerium
und dazu können wir uns einmal angucken
was die kandidaten gesagt haben als ich
bundesminister wurde im märz 2008
zehnter war gerade von bundesminister
schäuble organisiert worden das dfg die
financial intelligence unit drüber geht
zur toll dass dort die arbeit geleistet
wird die mitunter auf engen straßen
waren auch mehr mitarbeiter die mit
aufklärung von all den dingen verbunden
ist mit der geldwäsche mit dem
terrorismusfinanzierung und all den
dingen die dazu gehören und dann habe
ich eine behörde übernommen mit knapp
160 mitarbeitern die jetzt fast 500 hat
die demos 700 mitarbeiter haben hat ich
habe dafür gesorgt dass sie eine moderne
it bekommt eine neue leitung dafür
gesorgt dass mit den länderministerien
kriterien gemeinsam entwickelt werden
was ausgesucht werden soll und wir haben
alle dazu eingeladen dass sie möglichst
viele meldungen machen dass meldung
aufkommen ist gestiegen von knapp 50.000
auf jetzt fast 150000 das wird auch
weiter steigen sie haben die aufsicht
über geldwäsche sie haben diese
institution wir haben übrigens in
unserem wahlprogramm drin weil wir diese
defizite kannten diese institution ins
bundeskriminalamt zu integrieren und
nicht da wo sie jetzt ist
und sie sagen wir haben immer mehr
mitarbeiter es wird aber immer weniger
aufgeklärt und es wird so wenig bei der
geldwäsche aufgeklärt dass ein
staatsanwalt sagt ich brauche hier
weitere informationen und dann ein
richter verfügt dass eine solche
durchsuchung stattfinden kann und
deshalb herr scholz war das unangemessen
dass sie abfällig über die justiz
geredet haben das ist unangemessen das
machen populist in anderen ländern wenn
die kommen müssen sie sagen hier ich
lege alles offen und denen nicht
vorschreiben wie sie zur arbeit nahm und
mensch der eine fall jetzt wäre wo sie
keine verantwortung übernehmen wollen
für den nachgeordneten bereich den sie
haben ist das ja nicht der erste fall
so thomas jetzt muss es einer einordnen
du bitte
ein hitziger auftrag gewesen wo die
beiden aufeinander losgegangen sind die
körper muss jetzt ein bisschen sortieren
am besten anhand von zwei erste
dass diese financial intelligence unit
nicht so gut arbeitet wie sie eigentlich
arbeiten sollte das also der vorwurf die
eigentliche auftrag nämlich geld wer
schon als steuerhinterziehung
nachzugehen dass der nicht so gut
erfüllt wird wie man ist von einem
solchen spezialeinheit eigentlich
erwarten würde
nochmal ganz kurzen hintergrund dieses
engagement verlegt wurde noch unter dem
früheren finanzminister wolfgang
schäuble in den verantwortungsbereich
des zolls verlegt insofern war da hat er
olaf scholz etwas übernommen was den
vorgänger da schon in die wege geleitet
hat ein zentraler punkt in der
verteidigung von olaf scholz ja zu sagen
ich habe für diese unit viel getan ich
habe der wettbewerb ist die mehr
personal und eine bessere ausstattung
hat da stimmt so nicht ganz er hat
natürlich planstellen geschaffen
insgesamt soll rund 3000 aber diese
stellen sind natürlich nicht alle
besetzt ist als man kann stellen
schaffen aber die entscheidende sache
ist mir dann dass genug leute da sind um
den job zu machen und da war der
finanzminister war im geist oder der
zoll und diese keinen intelligence unit
insgesamt nicht so erfolgreich wie es
vielleicht hätte sein sollen der zweite
punkt ist der von
armin laschet das melde aufgang das
heißt wie gut geht eigentlich diese
ferne und als unit
den den verdachtsfällen nach da gab es
erhebliche kritik dass viele fans
einfach liegen geblieben sind das dann
nicht schnell genug und hat nicht mehr
effizient genug gearbeitet wurde
das ist etwas was auch der
bundesrechnungshof kritisiert hat und
das ist etwas was olaf scholz in seiner
antwort da sozusagen ein bisschen drüber
hinweg spielen wäre wenn man so will
indem er sagt dass das melde aufkommen
so stark gestiegen sei da hat dann aus
meiner sicht wirklich ein punkt wird
eine ist dass es weder aufkommt
staatsanwalts dass die findet dann eben
auch abgearbeitet werden es gibt
allerdings auch in dieser geschichte in
dieser komplizierten frage auch ein
punkt wo armin laschet nicht richtig
liegt er wirft olaf scholz vor dass das
finanzministerium die fachaufsicht über
das management klinik habe das bündnis
die rechtsaufsicht und das gehört sich
nach einem kleinen unterschied an in der
praxis ist es ein größerer rechtzeitig
bedeutet dass das finanzministerium
prüft ob diese financial intelligence
unit auch rechtsmäßig arbeitet wach auf
sich geht weiter und hat auch weitere
eingriffsrechte bringt es mit sich also
barragan armin laschet quatsch das heißt
wir hoffen dass die frage von herrn
reichert inwiefern hat lasche
tatsächlich tatsachen in bezug auf 1
scholz tätigkeit als finanzminister
verdreht damit beantwortet ist lieber
herr reichert
nee du bist erreicht ich weiß nicht ob
der kollege von youtube sehr die frage
stellt auch erreicht heißt es wäre ein
ein lustiger zufall auf jeden fall ist
die frage des zuschauers wie auch immer
er heißen mag hoffentlich damit von dir
beantwortet lieber thomas und eine
andere sache möchten wir noch mit ihr
besprechen nämlich die des abgeordneten
ins b maßen auch da haben wir
ein paar töne zusammengeschnitten hat
herr maßen für sie einen platz in der
cdu steht er in der mitte der partei er
ist mitglied der cdu